سعر اللاتيه في «هاف مليون» من يوم ما تأسس إلى اليوم ما تغيّر
مع أنه مَر...
حجمه صغر، وللا لا؟
لا هو نفس الحجم ونفس الكوب بس تغيرت الهوية، وهو نفس الحجم
عشرة ريال، وكان شامل الضريبة يوم كانت الضريبة 5%
مع زيادة الضريبة 15% برضو «هاف مليون» يتحمّل الضريبة
عندنا تقريبًا، تتكلم عن عشرين شاشة في غرفة
تشوفها تقول: 911
فيها الكاميرات اللي تصور الفروع
سواءً داخل المقهى، وللا في اللي يسمونه غرفة التخزين
أربع وعشرين ساعة يداومون
مغلقة، وفيها شاشات؟
إي، أربع وعشرين ساعة يداومون
بحيث يتابعون فيها العمليات، كيف تصير؟
وإذا كان في أي انحراف، يتواصل مباشرة مع الفرع
احنا سنويًّا، عدد فروعنا تتضاعف
انتهينا في 2020 بتسعة فروع
2021 أنهيناه في ثمانية عشرة فرع، فتتكلم الضعف
2022 يعني أنهينا السنة في أربعة وثلاثين فرع
فتتكلم أنت سنة عن سنة فروعنا تتضاعف
يالله حيّهم
ضيفنا اليوم صهيب البلوشي، الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة «هاف مليون»
وهي أحد أشهر العلامات التجارية في قطاع القهوة في السعودية
صهيب انضم لـ«هاف مليون» يوم كان عندهم سبع فروع
وخلال أقل من ثلاث سنوات من انضمامه
وصلوا إلى ثلاثة وأربعين فرع
ومستمرين في النمو بشكل كبير، ما شاء الله
وأدري ممكن تتساءل
ليش ما استضفتوا رئيس مجلس الإدارة «عبدالله الراجحي»
واستضفتوا الرئيس التنفيذي؟
لأن ببساطة تركيزنا في هذه الحلقة بكون على تفاصيل تشغيلية
ساعدتهم ينجحون ويكبرون في مجال مزدحم جدًّا بالمنافسين
تفاصيل زي كذا عادةً تأخذها من الرئيس التنفيذي
ما تأخذها من رئيس مجلس الإدارة
على سبيل المثال
أيش الإجراءات اللي يسوونها عشان يتحكمون بجودة المنتجات؟
سواءً في الفرع الواحد أو ما بين الفروع
كيف يطورون منتجاتهم على مدى السنة؟
وليش محافظين على سعرها زي ما هو بدون أي زيادة؟
مع أن التكاليف خلال السنين الماضية ارتفعت
سواءً من ضريبة ومن أسعار مورّدين وغيرها
سنغطي أيضًا موضوع تطبيقات التوصيل
وكيف قدروا يخلون نسبة مبيعاتهم من تطبيقات التوصيل ما تتجاوز 5%
عكس مقاهي كثير ثانية يمكن تتجاوز النسبة هذه أكبر بكثير؟
كيف يشوفون المنافسة في قطاع القهوة حاليًّا؟
وليش المقاهي عادةً تطلع من السوق؟ ومواضيع كثيرة غيرها
حلقة ثريّة جدًّا بالمعلومات، وأتوقع تفيد ناس كثير من أصحاب المقاهي
أو اللي ناوين يفتحون مقهى مستقبلًا
أترككم الآن مع الحلقة
حيّاك الله صهيب
الله يحييك
أخيرًا، كم لنا، سنة نتكلم عن موضوع الاستضافة؟
أيش يقولون؟ «ما أبطى من جاء»
إي، فسعيد جدًّا أنك موجود معنا اليوم
الله يعافيك، أنا أسعد
وقبلما أبدأ أنا عندي سؤال فضول
كهلالي، أيش شعورك، وأنتم راعين الشباب في «هاف مليون»؟
رعاية الشباب جاية من منطلق عمل تجاري بشكل أساسي
الميول الشخصية هذا جانب
والنشاط والشركة والعمل التجاري والمصلحات، هذا جانب ثاني
لا، أعرف هذا الشيء واضح جدًّا، بس أيش شعورك؟
شعور أي مواطن سعودي سعيد
أحس في تضارب ومشاعر اللي تشوف...
لا، أبدًا
خاصةً لما لعبوا قبل فترة الشباب والهلال تحس اللي....
تصدق بعد رعايتنا للشباب
لأن تأهُّل الشباب برضو ظهور إضافي لكم
رعايتنا للشباب مع أن ميولي هلالية
أشجع الهلال يمكن من عمري تسع سنوات
لكن، سبحان الله، جاء على مصلحة العمل التجاري تتمنى...
إذا جاء لعب الشباب مع الهلال، تتمنى الشباب يفوز
لأن فيها جانب مصلحة للعمل التجاري
فتغلب جانب العمل التجاري على الجانب الشخصي
تطغى مسألة أن تنجح في عملك أكثر من أنك...
فعلًا
الفريق عادي ممكن يفوز بعدين
فعلًا لاحقين، بعد الرعاية
بس الحين اللي أعرفه أن الموسم الجاي احتمال ما تجددون...
صحيح
هل هذا يعني أن التجربة كانت غير مناسبة؟
وللا قاعد تحاول ترعى الهلال؟
لا، احنا رعايتنا للشباب كانت لمدة ثلاثة مواسم
بدأت بعد كورونا من موسم 2021 إلى موسم 2023
فأعتقد سواءً الشباب، وللا أي نادي آخر
رعاية لمدة ثلاث مواسم أتوقع تكون مناسبة وكفاية
بحكم أن أول موسم راح يكون فيه بداية العلاقة
وبناء، وأيش يصير بالتوجه؟
راح تحصد ثمارها في الموسم الثاني والثالث
بعدين ممكن الإضافة تكون موجودة
لكن إضافة تكون جدًّا بسيطة على العلامة التجارية
فيصير في توجهات ثانية على مستوى التسويق احنا نأخذها
خلنا نخش الحين في الموضوع اللي أتوقع في بال كل مستمع الآن
اللي ليش تستضيف صهيب بدل «عبدالله الراجحي»؟
لأن أول ما أجيب طاري «هاف مليون»
مثلًا في سناب شات عندي، وللا في أي مكان
يقولون: راح تجيب «عبدالله الراجحي»
«عبدالله الراجحي» راح يطلع؟
فـ«عبدالله الراجحي» حسب علمي رئيس مجلس الإدارة
صحيح
ما هو الرئيس التنفيذي مثل منصبك
فغالبًا إذا تكلمت معه راح يعطيني الصورة من فوق
ما راح يعطيني التفاصيل، اللي راح تعطيني إياها
فهذه أنا ما أحتاج إجابتها
أنا أحتاج إجابة متى دخلت «هاف مليون»؟
كيف كان طبيعة ممكن...
أيش اللي خلّاك تتصادف مع «عبدالله الراجحي»
وتتكلمون في موضوع أنك تصير رئيس تنفيذي؟
خاصةً أنك جئت من برة القطاع، وما عمرك أدرت قهوة في حياتك
كنت دائمًا داخل في... أو شغّال في مناصب في مجالات ثانية
فمتى جئت «هاف مليون»؟
وأيش اللي خلّاهم يتكلمون معك بحيث أنك تصير رئيس تنفيذي؟
أتوقع أنني ماني بعيد جدًّا عن مجال المطاعم والمقاهي
بحكم أني قبلها كنت شغّال لمدة سنتين
كنائب رئيس تنفيذي في شركة «هنقرستيشن»
اللي لها علاقة في المطاعم والمقاهي بشكل أو بآخر
بس ما أدرت المقهى، أنت قاعد...
يعني ماخذ الجهة الأخرى من القطاع
اللي هو قاعد توصل لهم طلبات أكثر من...
أنا بالنسبة لي التشغيل في أي شركة وفي أي نشاط هو واحد
أنت عندك مدخلات، وعندك عمليات، وعندك مخرجات
فبالنسبة لأي شركة فيها تشغيل
سواءً في تطبيقات توصيل الطلبات أو سواءً مطاعم
أو سواءً مقاهي أو الصناعات
لو تلاحظها هي نفس الدائرة والمحيط
فما أعتقد كان فيها...، فيها اختلاف
لكن ما هو اختلاف جذري
أنا جئت والله من قطاع ثاني إلى قطاع ثاني
لا، كنت كلها في مجال المطاعم والمقاهي
أنتم تقاطعتم لأنك كنت في «هنقرستيشن» وهم كانوا...
فعلًا، صار تقريبًا بعد الحجر، نتكلم تقريبًا في يوليو 2020
في واحدة من المناسبات قابلت فيها الأخ «عبدالله الراجحي»
وتكلمنا كثير على توجّه «هاف مليون»
وعلى وين حاب توصل العلامة التجارية خلال الفترة الجاية؟
وعرض علي أني أمسك كرئيس تنفيذي
بحكم أن خلال الفترة هذه كان حاب يأسس أكثر من شركة
وخصوصًا في مجال التطوير العقاري
فيبي يركّز بشكل أساسي للشركات اللي راح تؤَسَّس
ويبي يسلّم الموضوع...
كرئيس تنفيذي يمسك مشروع «هاف مليون» خلال الفترة الجاية
وقتها «هاف مليون» كم فرع كان؟
كان سبعة فروع
في عام كم؟
في يوليو، 2020
وكان «هاف مليون» متواجد بس في رياض بسبعة فروع
و«هاف مليون» تأسس في 2018 في شهر مارس
بفرع واحد في شارع التحلية
فخلال فترة تقريبًا الثلاث سنوات إذا تقدر تسميها
من 2018 إلى 2020 وصلنا لسبع فروع
حلو، فهذه السبع فروع كم موظف تقريبًا؟
في الإدارة، وللا في الفروع؟
إجمالًا كم موظف؟
تقريبًا 102 أذكر
والإدارة كم كانت؟
الإدارة أذكر أول اجتماع معهم
تقريبًا حول أربعة عشر أو خمسة عشر موظف
آه لسه إدارة صغيرة، حلو فسبع فروع وأربعة عشر في الإدارة
والبقية كلهم من الـ100 وشوي هؤلاء بالفروع
صحيح بالفروع، اللي هم بين كاشير وصانع قهوة وعمال نظافة
واجد 100 على سبعة فروع؟
لا، لأن داخل فيها حقين المستودع
وداخل فيها حقين التوصيل، اللي هم السواقين
فلو قسمتهم راح يطلع عدد مناسب
بالإضافة أن عدد الفواتير وعدد العملاء جدًّا كبير
فيحتاج وجود العدد هذا خلال الفترة هذه
أيش كان مطلوب منك وقتها أول ما جئت «هاف مليون»؟
كان في رؤية، خليني أقول لك بشكل كذا عام
أن العلامة التجارية خلال الفترة الأولى
أثبت اللي يُسمى «إثبات المفهوم» أثبت نجاحه
بالقيم اللي هو طلع فيها، اللي هو جودة المنتجات وثباتها
وقيمة السعر أن السعر يكون في متناول الجميع
وحابين أنه يتوسع
فكان دوري الأساسي هو وضع الخطط والاستراتيجيات خلال الفترة الجاية
وكيف تتلاقى مع التوجه هذا؟
وبناء فريق العمل، والتأكد من تنفيذ الخطط الاستراتيجية
وكيف أن الشركة تكون بشكل مالي ناجحة خلال الفترة الجاية؟
هنا أيضًا سؤال يمكن أسأله نيابةً عن بعض المستمعين اللي...
بما أنه تابع لـ«عبدالله الراجحي» المفروض أن عنده موارد مالية كبيرة جدًّا
فيقدر ينجّح أي علامة تجارية يبغى يشتغل عليها
هذا ما هو أول مرة، دائمًا نسمعه
لكن ودي أجاوبك على شقيّن
الشق الأول أنا أعتقد أنه لـ«كل مجتهدٍ النصيب»
سواءً «عبدالله» لأنه جاء من عائلة «الراجحي»
أو من عائلة ثرية ثانية موجودة في السعودية
أو من عائلة فقيرة أو واحد مقطوع من شجرة
لـ«كل مجتهدٍ النصيب»
الأمر الثاني أعتقد فيه إجحاف للطرفين
طلّع صهيب من المعادلة
خلينا نتكلم عن «عبدالله الراجحي» ونتكلم على فريق «هاف مليون»
واحد اجتهد، وواحد ركز على مشروعه في الفترة هذه
فأكيد أن الله راح راح يرزقه ويوفقه، التوافيق بيد رب العالمين
لكن الله راح يرزقه على حسب الاجتهاد والشغل اللي يسويه
وعندك أمثلة تعرفها، وكثير نعرفها
علامات تجارية سواءً في المجال ولا غير المجال لعوائل
يعني تبع نفس العائلة، وللا عوائل ثرية
بعضها ما نجحت، وبعضها تعاني بشكل كبير، وبعضها أقفلت
ويمكن السوق واضح ومفتوح على الأمثلة هذه
فما أعتقد والله ربطها أن والله «عبدالله الراجحي»
ممكن ينجّح أي علامة تجارية
إذا ما كان في اجتهاد وفي تركيز، وهذا هو السبب الرئيسي
الأمر الثاني أنت عندك موظفين «هاف مليون» فمعناته...
خليني أعطيك مثال، خلال الفترة هذه
عندي موظفين الموارد البشرية يداومون تقريبًا
من عشر إلى ممكن أحيانًا تصل إلى أربعة عشر ساعة
عشان يتأكدون من موضوع التوظيف، وتأهيل الموظفين
ويكون عندنا تقريبًا عدد الموظفين
اللي نوظفهم شهريًّا تتكلم عن سبعين موظف
فمعناته خلاص يعول على أن العلامة التجارية تبع «عبدالله الراجحي»
خلاص، أنا ما أحتاج أني أشتغل عدد الساعات هذه
وما أحتاج أني أركّز بالشغل بهذه الطريقة
عندك حقين التسويق
أحيانًا في الحملات يقعدون ستة عشر ساعة في مكان التصوير
فمعناته إذا جئنا على نفس السبب
معناته خلاص ما يحتاج أركز
عشان تفاصيل الحملة ما تطلع بالطريقة اللي هم حابين تطلع فيها
ولا تطلع بذائقة اللي هي تناسب المشاهدين
حق المشتريات يفاصل على الهللات مع مورّدين الأكواب
فأعتقد فيها إجحاف للطرفين إذا ذكرناها...
لأن في ناس ينظرون لها بشكل أنه إذا الشخص كان من عائلة ثرية
فهو ببساطة راح يقعد يكب فلوس على المشروع إلى أن ينجح غصب
لا، ما هو صحيح
راح تمشي بالطيب أو بالقوة
أبدًا ما هو صحيح
راح تمشي راح تمشي
حتى كان فيه أذكر يوم كنت أصور في سناب شات
الحفل حق «هاف مليون»
وذكرتوا سبب تسمية «هاف مليون» أن كان تكلفة أول فرع نص مليون
صح
فكان فيه تعليقات، نص مليون على فرع قهوة!
أنا متأكد نص الناس هؤلاء
ما يدرون كم تكلف إنشاء فروع القهوة أو مقاهي
لكن برضو فيه التصور العام هذا
لكن مثلما قلت: في ناس كثير...
وإضافةً للكلام هذا، بالعكس أنه تابع لعائلة «الراجحي»
أحيانًا يسبب ضغط علينا
كثير مثلًا مورّدين نتعامل معه، يرفع لك السعر
عندكم فلوس يا أخي
إي، فيجيك من المبدأ هذا، والمبدأ هذا متعب
عامل موجود في أي نقاش مع أي مورّد
سواءً يقدم منتجات وللا يقدم خدمات
أن والله تبع... فيحاول أن يرفع السعر
وللا يحاول أن يقول: عندك فلوس
أو أي تعامل فهذا عامل موجود
فبالعكس، أن تلقى عامل متعب في بعض الأحيان
أكيد في فوائد كبيرة في الموضوع
لكن برضو في جانب متعب الناس ما قاعد تناظر له
أتصور حتى شوي متعب نفسيًّا لك وللفريق اللي...
يمكن «مشعل» بالتسويق
أعرفكم وأعرف كم واحد من فريق العمل من زمان
أتذكر دائمًا نجلس، ونسولف عن الشغل
عن أيش تشتغلون عليه، ووين رايحين؟
فأحس متعب نفسيًّا شوي أنك تشوف التطور هذا الكبير اللي تسوونه
كفريق عمل حتى ما هو لك شخصيًّا
وبعدين يقولون: إيه، أكيد هذا للـ«الراجحي»
لا، للأمانة خلاص صرنا ما هو، ما نركز عليه بشكل كبير وخلاص
وخصوصًا الإدارة، كرئيس مجلس الإدارة مقدّر الأمر
والحمد لله، شايفين رضا العملاء، هذا بالنسبة لنا يكفينا
أكثر الموضوع أنه يُنسَب لصهيب وللا يُنسَب لفلان
ولا يُنسَب لـ«عبدالله» للأمانة هذه ما تهمنا
بس ماليًّا هم إلى متى استمروا يصرفون عليها
عشان يتأكدون أنه على الأقل يوقف على رجله؟
خلني أقول لك، ما ودي، في معلومات ما أقدر أشاركها معك
لكن آخر كم سنة، ما في أي ضخ مادي، كلها عن طريق مبيعات الفروع
وعن طريق ممكن جهات تمويلية اللي هي البنوك
اللي تأخذ بضمانات نقاط البيع
فالشركة شايلة نفسها بنفسها من كم سنة
أتوقع هذه أولوية عندهم برضو
أن تكون الشركة شايلة نفسها بنفسها
زي أي شركة ثانية يبغون يستثمرون فيها
صحيح، لا يتوقع الناس أن والله تبع العائلة معناته الصبر عالي عندهم
بقدر ما أنه لا خلاص
في نماذج كثيرة موجودة عندهم
فيبغونها تنجح بشكل أسرع، وتشيل نفسها بشكل أسرع
لأن آخر شيء يبغى يسويه حتى الشخص الثري
أن يكون عنده مشروع عبارة عن محرقة فلوس
صحيح
ما غير تشفط منك كل سنة، ومو قادر ينمّيه
وصلتوا الآن كم، تقريبًا ثلاثة وأربعين فرع؟
ثلاثة وأربعين فرع
ودي نسولف عن التجربة هذه في التوسع
وكيف بدأت فيها من سبعة فروع انطلاقتكم من هناك
كيف قررت تسويه؟
هل تقول: أنك تريد التوسع في الرياض؟
وللا أحاول أنتشر في المناطق أو كيف كانت؟
ممتاز، خليني أقول لك: أنا انضممت
أو مسكت إدارة «هاف مليون» في نهاية 2020
كان وقتها لمدة ستة شهور ما توسعنا في أي فرع
ركزنا خلال الستة شهور الأولى في موضوع بناء فريق العمل
فسوّينا تحليل على موضوع...
لأن في النهاية ممكن توسع فرع أو فرعين، وممكن كل شهر أفتح فرع
لكن هذه ستكون متعبة، لأن الأساس ما كان صحيح
أيش النواقص اللي كانت؟
بس حاب أوضح، مو معناته أن الأساس كان غلط
بالعكس الأساس كان صح وموجود
لكن إذا الشركة راح تمر في مرحلة توسّع بشكل كبير خلال الفترة الجاية
فلازم طريقة العمل وفريق العمل يكون بشكل مختلف
خليني أقول لك: من الشغلات اللي احنا اشتغلنا عليها
موضوع وضع نظام ضبط الجودة بشكل محكم وكبير خلال التوسّع
لأن في النهاية من أهم أسباب فشل الشركات
في مجال المطاعم والمقاهي هو تذبذب الجودة
فحرصنا أن أول شيء نركز عليه موضوع الجودة
أنت الظاهر درست الموضوع هذا قبل، صح؟
أخذته في دراستك في الجامعة؟
إيه، أنا تخصصي هندسة صناعية
وندرس أكثر من فصل في الجامعة عن إدارة وتحكم الجودة
بالإضافة اشتغلت بداية حياتي في شركة «جنرال إلكتريك»
اشتغلت كمهندس جودة لمدة سنتين
فهذا أعطاني بعض الأساسيات في تحكم الجودة وضبطها
فأنت يهمك إذا صار عندك بدال سبع فروع، صار في خمسة عشر فرع
يهمك إذا شربت قهوة هنا أو هنا نفس الطعم
بالضبط، وزي ما قلت لك: تذبذب الجودة
واحدة من أهم الأسباب فشل الشركات في مجال المطاعم والمقاهي
لأنه لو جئت فكرت فيها العميل عنده
أعطيك على سبيل المثال، دائمًا أقولها
حتى على مستوى الفرع الواحد؟
حتى على مستوى الفرع الواحد
عندك مثلًا الشارع اللي هنا شارع «أنس بن مالك»
تتكلم فوق الستين فرع، ستين مقهى مختص
و«هاف مليون» واحدة من الفروع
فأيش اللي يخلي العميل إذا ما أعجبته جودة القهوة والمنتج يجي لك
ويترك التسعة وخمسين خيار الثاني؟ فعنده خيارات واجد
ومع ذلك يقررون يسون زحمة عندنا على الفرع حقكم
فهو يعتمد على رأي العميل، أذكر على سبيل المثال
لأن صراحةً موضوع الجودة، أنا دائمًا أتكلم فيه مع الفريق
وأقول لهم: دائمًا الشركة إذا راح تطيح بسبب تذبذب الجودة
إذا في تذبذب في الجودة عندنا في المنتجات والخدمات
هذه بداية سقوط الشركة
أذكر قبل في 2010 أو 2011، كان في الجامعة
كان في سكن الجامعة، كان في مطعم، ما ودّي أقول اسمه
بس مشاوي ويبيع شاورما، معروف وقتها
وكان نظام سكن الجامعة في الـ....
جامعة «الملك فهد للبترول»؟
إيه
غريبة ما قلت اسمها؟
أنا حاول أكسر القاعدة
اللي يقول لك: كيف تعرف واحد درس في البترول، راح يعلّمك
أنا حاول أكسر القاعدة، فأنت قلتها أنا ما قلتها
فتتكلم على 2010 أو 2011 الفترة هذه
كان نظام الجامعة ممنوع دخول التوصيل
ما كان فيه تطبيقات توصيل
وكان ممنوع دخول التوصيل سواقين المطاعم
اللي في الظهران والخبر للجامعة
لأنه كان عندها سياسة معينة
إذا تبي تستلم تروح عند بوابة الجامعة تستلم طلبك
فكان الخيارات الموفَّرة منها المطعم
هذا حق البروستد والشاورما الموجود
وكانت بقية الخيارات جدًّا بسيطة
كان الفرع هذا، كان فرع واحد موجود داخل السكن
وكان يوصل برضو لطلاب الجامعة
أيش هو، مقهى ولا؟
لا، مطعم يبيع شاورما وبروستد ومشويات
كان المطعم، في عنده توصيل
وأغلب أو كان في كثير من طلاب الجامعة ما عندهم سيارات
صعب أنه مثلًا اللي يبي يتغدى أو يتعشى يشغل سيارته
ويطلع من سكن الجامعة يروح للخبر أو الظهران يتغدى أو يتعشى
فكان اعتمادية بشكل كبير على المطعم هذا
المطعم على قولتهم: لا أحكيلك، تذبذب جودة
وتطلب اثنين الظهر ما يوصل لك ممكن إلا أربعة ونص
طلبك ممكن يوصل ناقص دائمًا، من خمسة طلبات تطلبها
لازم ثلاثة أو أربع مرات يكون ناقص الطلب
كان سعر التوصيل ريال، ورفعه إلى ثلاثة ريال، وأنت مجبور
وكان فيه احتقان كبير من طلاب الجامعة
وكان فيه ضغط على إدارة الجامعة أن يوفرون خيارات ثانية
فلما إدارة الجامعة استجابت وقتها
وكانوا يأسسون مول الجامعة، وكان فيه عدة علامات تجارية لمطاعم
تخيّل أول ما افتحت، ما كمل سنة هذاك إلا قفّل
بتقول ليش كان؟ مع أنه كان وقتها قبلما يفتح الـ...
المفروض كل أحد يعرفه، هو الأساس
كان على قولتهم: أول ما يخطر بالبال
أي واحد يبي يتغدى أو يتعشى يجي لهذا، مع أنه معاناة
لكن في النهاية طلاب الجامعة محدودين، ما عندهم إلا الخيار هذا
هذه قيسها على السوق الآن
فأول خيارات المطاعم والمقاهي قليلة
أذكر في 2015 بدأت اللي تقدر تسميها هبة القهوة المختصة
إذا شفت مقهى مختص دائمًا زحمة عليه، لأن الخيارات محدودة
الآن تفتح قهوة مختصة، ما تفرق حتى تبيع قهوة بطعم ممتاز
أكثر من البقالات في الشمال على الأقل
فصار ما فيه ميزة تنافسية للأمانة
فما بالك إذا صار فيه تذبذب في موضوع الجودة؟
فعشان كذا أقول لك: موضوع ضبط الجودة واحدة من أهم الشغلات
اللي اشتغلنا عليها في مرحلة البناء
حلو، بس يجي واحد راعي مقهى مثلًا يقول لك: ممتاز، كلام جميل
أيش أسوي عشان أضبط الجودة؟
خليني أقول لك: أيش الإجراءات اللي احنا مشينا فيها؟
أول شيء وظّفنا الفريق، ووظّفنا مدير الجودة
وظّفت فريق مختص في ضبط الجودة؟
إيه، بدأنا في المدير
أيش مؤهلاتهم، أيش خبرتهم؟
يكون في السوق، في كثير من العلامات التجارية اللي عندها عدة فروع
يصير عندها مدير جودة
يوم وظفنا، قلنا: نبي نشوف الممارسات اللي تصير في السوق
في موضوع، كيف ضبط الجودة في المطاعم والمقاهي؟
يوم اطلعنا على كثير منها، وحتى في شركات عالمية
90% منها كان غير مرضي بالنسبة لنا وغير مقبول
ليش؟
سأقول لك: أيش كان دورهم؟
كان دور مسؤول الجودة، وللا فريق الجودة في...
خلينا نقول العلامة التجارية إكس
كان عنده قائمة تدقيق، وعنده جدولة، وزيارة فروع
«قائمة التدقيق» (check list) اللي هي قائمة؟
قائمة تدقيق، يكون فيها مثلًا ثلاثين إلى ستين بند
يمر الفرع بشكل عشوائي، وعنده جدول مع الفريق عنده
لكن عشوائي أو مفاجئ بالنسبة للتشغيل، عشان ما يكونوا مجهزين
أو يكونوا محضرين أو معدلين أي شغلة في التشغيل
اللي هم فريق التشغيل؟
إىه، فيجي يجيب لك قائمة التدقيق يعبيها
يقول لك: والله المنتج صح، لا هنا فيه التحضير غلط
أيش يكون في القائمة هذه عادةً؟
نظافة المكان، وطريقة التحضير، وجودة المنتج
هل فيه تغيير؟
هو يجي يتحقق؟
يتحقق من لبس الموظفين
فيتحقق من زي ما قلت لك: من ثلاثين لستين بند تقريبًا
يتحقق ويعبيها، وفي نهاية اليوم يرسل تقرير
ويزورهم بشكل مفاجئ عشان ما يكونون مستعدين؟
إيه، وبعدين يرسل التقرير لفريق التشغيل
ونأخذه للعمل، بحيث يعدلون الموضوع
هذه من الإدارة، بس من الفرع مين اللي يضبط الجودة؟
مدير الفرع وللا؟
مدير الفرع ومدير التشغيل هم المسؤولين عن ضبط الجودة
فهذا دور فريق الجودة قدر ما هو بس يعطيك وين الخلل موجود
أو كأنه جهة أو إدارة رقابية موجودة في الشركة
فيرسل لفريق التشغيل ممكن يأخذ تصرف، وممكن ما يأخذ
يجي بعد شهر، الزيارة تجيء تقريبًا، نفس الأخطاء قاعد تتكرر
فهذه ما تناسبنا، لأننا احنا في مرحلة توسّع كبيرة
مدير الفرع قاعد تجيه ملاحظات، ليش ما يصلحها؟
خليني أقول لك: في كثير من الشركات الموجودة في القطاع
دائمًا فريق التشغيل أقوى بكثير من فريق الجودة
ليش؟
بحكم أنه يجيب المبيعات، وبحكم أنه يسمونه الجزء الأساسي
هو الواجهة
وما يصير في تركيز على موضوع الجودة
في فريق جودة وعندنا معايير، لكن لو جئت على أرض الواقع، مين أقوى؟
تشوف فريق التشغيل هم الأقوى
أتصور واضح أنك تكون تهتم بالجودة على أساس تقدر...
فريق التشغيل حتى يعطي أكثر...
أنا أقول لك: هذه من الممارسات اللي شفناها في 2020 تقريبًا
أكيد فيه نماذج ممتازة، ونماذج بالنسبة لنا نعتبر تسمى قدوة
نقتدي فيها
لكن فكثير من الممارسات كانت شفناها ما هي جيدة
للمرحلة اللي احنا نبي نكون موجودين فيها
فجئنا قلنا: قبل هذا كله نبي «كيه بي آي»
يعني نبي مؤشر أداء واحد
إذا شفناه عرفنا أن احنا نؤدي بشكل جيّد في الجودة وللا سيّء
ليش واحد؟
خلاص، أعطيك مثال: لو جئت قلت لك: مبيعات
قلت لك: والله الفرع الفلاني يبيع إكس
راح يجيك مؤشر، هذا يؤدي أداء جيّد
قلت لك: والله ربح الفرع وللا ربح الشركة بشكل عام
تتكلم على 20% أو 25% أو 30% فيعطيك...
فأنت تبغى لتسهيل المتابعة
لتسهيل المتابعة نبي...
مؤشر أداء واحد
إيه، فجئنا اشتغلنا على موضوع مؤشر الأداء، أيش هو؟
هل هو اللي يسمونه «نجم الشمال»
إيه، خلاص أنا رقم واحد إذا شفته في الصباح
أعرف أن احنا قاعدين نؤدي بشكل جيّد أو بشكل سيء
فجئنا هنا وطلعنا بمؤشر أداء اسمه نسبة التواصل
اللي هو معدل الاتصال
هذا معدل الاتصال معروف في شركات خدمة العملاء والأقسام
الشركات الناشئة كثير بعد يستخدمون معدل الاتصال
فاحنا جئنا طبقناه...
بس لو تشرح أيش معدل الاتصال؟
معدل الاتصال
الفكرة منها جئنا قلنا: لو جئت قلت لك: يا مشهور عدد الشكاوى
في «هاف مليون» الأسبوع الماضي أربعين شكوى جيّد ولا سيئ؟
بدون سياق، ما أعرف
لو قلت لك: 100 أو 200
بس لو قلت لك: 100 شكوى من مليون طلب؟
إيه، لا هنا يصير في سياق واضح
فجئنا هنا على موضوع أنه كم عدد الشكاوى مقابل عدد الطلبات
فالنسبة هذه هي الـنسبة التواصل
فتطلع لك نسبة، إذا زادت الطلبات برضو النسبة تتغير
صحيح
مجرد أن فيه أربعين شكوى مستمرة
خلينا نقول: كل أسبوع فيه أربعين شكوى بس الطلبات قاعدة تزيد
بالضبط
فوضعكم في السليم
بالضبط، فهذا كان أول خطوة أخذناها بعدما أقرّينا أن في فريق
وهي تقسم عدد الطلبات على الشكاوى
لا، عدد الشكاوى على عدد الطلبات
عفوًا، عدد الشكاوى على عدد الطلبات
فصار هذا هو بالنسبة لنا مؤشر الأداء اللي نركز عليه
بالإضافة ربطنا مؤشر الأداء هذا
ما صار بس لفريق التشغيل، صار مسؤول عنه فريق التشغيل
وفريق الجودة وفريق التدريب
بس هذا الحين مؤشر الأداء هذا، كل فرع يدري كم المؤشر حقه؟
بالضبط، بشكل يومي، ويوصل تقريبًا بشكل أسبوعي مفصّل
حلو، فطلبات الفرع واضحة، التواصل شلون تحسبونه؟
شكاوى العملاء عن طريق وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وعن طريق قوقل ماب
فعندنا تقريبًا أربع منصات تواصل عن طريق تويتر وإنستقرام
حتى تيك توك نستقبل فيه شكاوى
وعن طريق قوقل ماب، وبالإضافة لتطبيق «هاف مليون»
ومين الفريق الداخلي اللي عندكم اللي يحصر عددها؟
في فريق خدمة عملاء، وبرضو أسسنا فريق خدمة عملاء
بحيث يتابع شكاوى العملاء، ويتابع برضو أداء الفروع من الكاميرات
فصرنا واحدة من الإجراءات اللي أخذناها، صار عندنا غرفة...
راح نجيء على الكاميرات هذه
بس فريق خدمة العملاء أتصور يطلّع مثلًا تقرير يومي
يقول: هذه الشكوى على الفرع الفلاني، وهذه الشكوى على الفرع الفلاني
صحيح
وأنت عندك المبيعات، فتقدر تقول: هذه النسبة حق الـ...
بالضبط
أيش اسمه؟
نسبة التواصل
معدل الـ...؟
معدل الاتصال
معدل الاتصال عند الفرع هذا كذا وكذا
اللي تشوف عنده ضارب معدل الاتصال معناته الوضع يحتاج تدخل
التقارير تصل بشكل يومي للفروع، وأنا أكون موجود في البريد الإلكتروني
وبشكل أسبوعي يصير فيه ثلاث اجتماعات متابعة صوت العميل
فيه اجتماعات بين فريق الجودة...
صوت العميل؟
صوت العميل، يصير في متابعة لشكاوى وملاحظات العملاء
من فريق الجودة مع فريق التشغيل
وفي من فريق التشغيل ومع مدراء الفروع
وفي معي أنا كإدارة شركة مع فريق التشغيل
أنت الآن عرفت معدل الاتصال، كيف توصّل لهم نوعية المشاكل؟
هل مثلًا تقول عندي أنواع من المشاكل راح أوزعها عليها
وللا تعطي تفاصيل حتى المشاكل؟
لا، مقسمينهم، عندنا تقريبًا إحدى عشر قسم للشكاوى
في شكوى على المنتج وجودة المنتج
وفي شكوى على مثلًا الخدمة نفسها
وفي مشكلة على تعامل فريق العمل
وفي إشكالية على موضوع
إذا كان عنده مشكلة في تطبيق «هاف مليون»
في مشكلة إذا كان عنده مشكلة صيانة
في بعض الفروع بحكم أن أغلب فروعنا الآن فيها طلبات سيارة
يجينا ملاحظة على الرصيف، وملاحظات بشكل عام
فمقسمينها إلى أحد عشر تصنيف
مسويها تصنيف عشان ما تضطر ترسل له تعليقات طويلة
ويقعد يقرأها واحد واحد
بالضبط، مع أنه ترسل لهم تعليقات، لكن مصنفة كتصنيفات
كتصنيف أسهل، يشوف أرقام وخلاص
بالضبط
فزي ما قلت لك: يصير في ثلاث اجتماعات أسبوعية
بحيث أن يصير في متابعة على موضوع الجودة
بس ودي أرجع لك نقطة اللي هو ربطنا مؤشر الأداء هذا في ثلاثة أقسام
فحتى فريق الجودة صار هو يهتم
بتقييمه وحرصه على أن معدل الاتصال هذا يقل
لو جئت للممارسات اللي زي ما قلت لك إياها في الشركات
فريق الجودة أهم شيء أن يسوي الزيارات، ويرسل التقارير
تعدلت كان بها، وإذا ما تعدلت الشكوى لله
فهنا لا، حتى أقول لهم، لفريق الجودة: أنت المسؤول الأول
حتى مدير الجودة دائمًا أقول له: أنت أقوى واحد في الشركة
وما أقولها: بشكل نظري، لا أقول له: أنت أقوى واحد في الشركة
حتى في كثير من الأحيان تصير أن عنده مشاكل في ماكينة القهوة
وللا مشاكل في مطحنة معينة
فيصير فريق الجودة له الحق أن يوقف المنتج، يوقف الماكينة هذه
صح راح يتعّب الفريق التشغيلي أن يعتمد على المكائن الثانية
وممكن يسبب في تأخير العملاء
لكن مسألة أنك أنت تعرف أنه في إشكالية وتمشّي، هذا خط أحمر
أنت لك القدرة أنك توقّف متى ما شفت احتمالية
أن فيه خلل المنتج هذا للمنتج النهائي
شعارنا لا تمشّي وإلا بمشّيك
عندك برضو ربطنا حوافز الفريق اللي بالفروع...
بس دقيقة قبل الحوافز، أيش سالفة الكاميرات؟
غرفة المراقبة اللي سويتوها
إيه، عندنا تقريبًا تتكلم عن عشرين شاشة في غرفة
تشوفها تقول: 911
فيها الكاميرات تصور لك الفروع
سواءً في داخل المقهى وللا في غرفة التخزين
فهنا حتى قبلما يشتكي العميل، في فريق خدمة العملاء برضو يتابع...
هذا يكون فريق في الإدارة في غرفة كذا تصور الفروع
إيه، أربع وعشرين ساعة يداومون
مغلقة فيها شاشات
بحيث يتابعون فيها العمليات، كيف قاعدة تصير؟
وإذا كان في أي انحراف يتواصل مباشرة مع الفرع
هذا يتواصل مباشرة بحيث يأخذ الفعل أو الإجراء بشكل سريع
دقيقة أنا الحين عندي أكثر من سؤال جاء في بالي
أول شيء، كم واحد يشرف على العملية هذه
إذا عندك ثلاثة وأربعين فرع؟
تتكلم تقريبًا خمسة إلى ستة موظفين
وراح أجيئك على السؤال الثاني بس قبلها أبغى أعرف
هل أنتم بنيتوا العملية هذه بناءً على معايير معينة في السوق
وللا اخترعت الـ...
لا، خليني أقول لك: مستوى الجودة ومستوى ضبط الجودة
في كل مرحلة لازم تتحسن
فكلما توسعت في فروعنا...
فطريقة إدارتنا فيها لازم يكون فيها صرامة أكثر
ولازم يكون فيها ضبط أكثر
بس هذا معيار في السوق يستخدمونه، ويحطون كاميرات في كل مكان؟
في بعض الشركات تطبقها
لكن أقول لك: احنا بالنسبة لنا
كان هذا مناسب بالنسبة لنا أن نطبقه خلال المرحلة...
وشلون يتابع العدد الكبير هذا من الفروع؟
بشكل عشوائي، يشوف مثلًا الفرع الفلاني
إذا فيه ممارسات تصير واضحة؛ يتواصل معه
فهو يتنقل بين الشاشات، ويشوف إذا أحد...
هذه خليني أقول لك: تدقيق بشكل عشوائي
زي المراقب بس أنه طول الوقت
بحيث يتابع العمليات بشكل عشوائي
وإذا اكتشف في خلل، أيش يسوي؟
يتواصل مباشرة مع الفرع
شلون يتواصل مع الفرع؟
عن طريق الجوّال أو عن طريق البريد الإلكتروني
يقول له: لاحظنا واحد، اثننين، ثلاثة. فالرجاء تعديل الملاحظات هذه
نعم، فيعني يدق عليه على طول، ويضبط الوضع
حتى رسائل البريد الإلكتروني نحرص أنها ما تكون كثيرة بس من باب التوثيق
لكن في الموضوع هذا خذ إجراء سريع
إذا لاحظت فيه انحراف على طول تواصل مع مدير الفرع
خصوصًا فريق خدمة العملاء كلهم جاءوا من الفروع
كلهم كانوا بدأوا معنا ككاشير، وبعضهم صانع قهوة
بعدين ترقوا، وصاروا في خدمة الـ...
يعرف وين يناظر
فعارفين التفاصيل
وما في أحد في فريق خدمة العملاء في «هاف مليون» برة الـ ...
ما جاء من الفروع، بحيث أنه عارف التفاصيل وعارف أيش الـ...
وعنده علاقة جيّدة مع الفروع
إذا صار فيه مشكلة عميل مع واحد، حرفيًّا فيه «مراقبة» ترجعون له
على طول يرجع له
فهذا جانب حرصنا أن يكون موجود
وبرضو المشاكل والتحديات اللي تجينا بشكل دائم
استخدمنا أداة معروفة اللي هي «ستة سيقما» لحل المشاكل المتكررة
على قولتهم، إلى متى احنا نكمل
وتكون عندنا نفس المشاكل ونفس الملاحظات
أيش هي الـ «ستة سيقما»؟
الـ«ستة سيقما» هي أداة معروف عنها
لتحسين الانحراف في العمليات بشكل مبسط
وتمر في خمس مراحل
المرحلة الأولى: مرحلة إذا كانت المشكلة تتكرر
عرّف المشكلة أول شيء، وحط حجمها
بعدين المرحلة الثانية، مرحلة القياس
فتقيس أثر المشكلة، وتحط بالنسبة لك مؤشرات الأداء
اللي راح تقيس فيها المشكلة هذه، وكيف راح تُحَل
المرحلة الثالثة: مرحلة التحليل، فتحلل المشكلة
وتحلل هي جاية من وين، وأيش السبب الأكبر بالنسبة لها؟
والمرحلة الرابعة: مرحلة أنك تحط خطة عمل
بحيث أنها لا تتكرر المشكلة بشكل دائم
والمرحلة الأخيرة اللي جدًّا مهمة هي مرحلة التحكم
بحيث تتأكد أنه بعدما تحط الإجراءات التصحيحية
خلاص المشكلة هذه ما راح تتكرر بالنسبة لي
والنظام اللي حطيته راح يمنع حدوث المشكلة هذه
وإذا طلعت تطلع بشكل واضح
ما يجيك ردة فعل من رئيس مجلس الإدارة أو أي أحد تشتغل معاه
مثلًا موظف جديد، يقول لك: وراك شادّها شوي؟
بالعكس
كاميرات و«ستة سيقما»
أنا قلت لك: من أهم أسباب تعثر كثير من الشركات في المجال
مسألة تذبذب الجودة
هي حلوة ما أقول لك: أنها سيئة
بس المقصد أنه خاصةً في قطاع المطاعم والمقاهي
أحس أن ممكن الناس يجونك من شركات ثانية
راح يقولون: أيش قاعد تسوي؟
أنا راح أقول لك إياها: احنا سنويًّا عدد فروعنا تتضاعف
انتهينا في 2020 كنا بتسع فروع
2021 أنهيناه في ثمانية عشر فرع، فتتكلم ضعف
2022 أنهينا السنة بأربعة وثلاثين فرع
فتتكلم أنت سنة عن سنة فروعنا تتضاعف
فلازم يكون فيها خليني أقول لك: شدة هذه الي سمّيتها
في موضوع ضبط الجودة، عشان أتأكد والله العميل...
لأن احنا واحدة من القيم اللي احنا على قولتهم نزعم فيها في «هاف مليون»
إن احنا قاعدين نقدم جودة عالية وثابتة
فكيف أقول شيء وفي النهاية احنا ما نسوي الإجراء
بحيث يساعدنا نوصل المرحلة هذه؟
ذكرنا الجودة، ما أنسى ذكر فريق التدريب
في واحدة من الإجراءات اللي أخذناها
قلنا: الحين الموظفين مين راح يدربهم؟
أغلب الموظفين في القطاع تلقاه يتدرب بعدما يتم توظيفه
يروح إلى الفرع، ويشوف الممارسات، ويتعلم ويتدرب
بس جودة التدريب ما هي عالية
راح نجي على تدريب الموظفين وعلى الموضوع هذا
الحين ضبط الجودة، هل في شيء ثاني ما غطيناه؟
بعد الإجراءات هذه اللي تقول: شادينها
واضح أنها حزّت بخاطرك
بالعكس، تحسّن عندنا معدل الاتصال
لو أخذناها خلال السنتين الماضية تقريبًا 65%
فقل عندنا معدل الاتصال بشكل 65%
ودائمًا نطمح أن يكون أقل
والتجربة تؤشر أن المؤشر يدل أن التجربة سلسة
بالضبط
الواحد يأخذ طلبات ولا يشتكي، والأمور كلها تمام
وتحت مؤشر الاتصال، في مؤشرات ثانية يتبعونها وللا؟
في اللي هو زيارة الفروع أو يسمونها التدقيق، هذا برضو في مؤشر
كل ملاحظة إذا مسؤول الجودة راح الفرع
فيقسّم، هل هذا شيء حسّاس، هل هو شيء كبير؟
بحيث أنه مثلًا، لا سمح، الله لقى شيء منتهي صلاحيته أو شيء
هذا يُصنَّف كحسّاس
وفي الصنف الثاني يُعتَبَر ملاحظة كبيرة
وفي ملاحظة متوسطة وفي ملاحظة صغيرة
فهذه المؤشرات برضو احنا نقيسها بشكل...
خلينا نتكلم على موضوع، كيف أول شيء تختارون أماكن فروعكم؟
وكيف تقررون نوعية الفرع، هل الفرع كبير أو صغير؟
هل في طلبات سيارة وللا ما في؟
وهل، وهذه يمكن، ودّي تجاوب عليها أول شيء
هل قد قفلت فرع قبل كذا، لأن ما كان أداءه جيّد؟
لا، الحمدلله، من ثلاثة وأربعين فرع، ما في فرع قفلناه
كلها مستمرة معنا إلى الآن
مو معناته أن كل فروعنا بأداء واحد
أكيد في اختلاف في الفروع على حسب المدينة والمنطقة والشارع
كيف تختار مكان ونوعية الفرع؟
عندنا فريق إدارة عقارات، فتبدأ العملية من عنده
نحدد في البداية المدينة، على سبيل المثال مدينة الرياض
نحدد وين أهم الشوارع وأهم الأحياء اللي احنا راح نكون موجودين فيها
يعتمد على أكثر من جانب
فيها الكثافة السكانية الموجودة في الحي
وفيها الشارع، وكيف الحركة الموجودة فيه؟
فيه العلامات التجارية الموجودة في الشارع تعطي مؤشر
هل الفرع هذا إذا فتحناه يؤدي بشكل جيّد وللا لا؟
فكل هذه المعايير نأخذها
ونحدد أن خلاص نبي فرع في الشارع الفلاني
أيش اللي يخليك تقرر أنه في طلبات سيارة أو ما في؟
احنا أول فرع لنا طلبات سيارات كان في شهر مايو، 2020
كان طريق القصيم «طريق الملك فهد»
وأثبت الفرع للأمانة نجاحها، وخيار مريح بالنسبة للعملاء
أنه يطلب عن طريق طلبات السيارات
فبعدها أخذنا توجّه كل التوسعات اللي بالنسبة لنا
تكون فروع فيها طلبات سيارات إلا في بعض الفروع يكون فيها استثناء
لكن حاليًّا، في 2020 كان فرع واحد بس فيه طلبات سيارات
الآن احنا نتكلم في ثلاثين فرع عندنا طلبات سيارات
75% من فروعنا فيها طلبات سيارات
وتوفير خدمة طلبات السيارة، هل لها اشتراطات معينة؟
وللا مجرد ما عندك المساحة تقدمها؟
لا، في اشتراطات احنا نقدم عليها
ونأخذها مع الأمانة والبلديات بحيث يتم اعتمادها
صعبة وللا؟
يعتمد صراحةً من منطقة لمنطقة، لكن...
ما أشوفها منتشرة عند المقاهي الثانية
لا بالعكس، في الرياض الحين بدأت تنتشر بشكل كبير
الآن خليني أقول لك: طريق بس...
أنا أعرف مثلًا دانكن دونتس وستاربكس
هؤلاء هم اللي يجون في بالي، وأنتم تقدمون الـ...
لا، في كذا علامة تجارية شغالين فيه، بالعكس حتى تشوف أنه مثلًا
خصوصًا بعد كورونا توجّه السوق كامل أو كثير من العلامات التجارية
سواءً مقاهي وللا مطاعم برقر وللا حتى شاورما الحين دخلوا في الخط
يتوسعون بطلبات خدمة السيارات
وحجم الفرع، أيش اللي يحدده؟
ما شاء الله، عندكم فروع كبيرة جدًّا، وعندكم فروع هالكبر
هنا جينا على موضوع أن نحتاج نحط معيار واضح بالنسبة لنا
موضوع كم مساحة الفرع، وكم واجهة الفرع؟
وكم العمق اللي نحتاجه بالفرع؟
فلاحظنا، نبي احنا زي ما قلت لك: نبي يكون في ثبات
في مستوى الجودة والخدمة في كل فروعنا
فهنا سوينا واحدة من العمليات اللي هي تحليل جذور المشكلة
ليش عندي فروع تتأخر وفروع أداءها جدًّا ممتاز؟
فحللنا الموضوع بشكل عام
واكتشفنا أن واجهة الفرع تحتاج تقريبًا تكون بطول 9.5 متر
خلاص اعتمدنا أن 9.5 متر هذا هو الواجهة بالنسبة لنا
لأن عندنا مكائن، وعندنا الأدوات اللي احنا نستخدمها، وكيف أريحية
حتى بين الواجهة والواجهة في مسافة معينة معتمدينها
حتى حجم المستودع عشان برضو ما يكون في انقطاعات
والفريق برضو يأخذ راحته في موضوع التجهيز إذا كان في ضغط
برضو طلعنا بمعيار مواحد
فبعدها فريق الجودة طلع منهم الموضوع، واعتمده فريق التشغيل
بعدين خلاص صار بالنسبة لفريق العقارات إذا جاء يدور موقع
خلاص عنده اشتراطات واضحة بالنسبة له
حتى صار يتكلم بلغة التشغيل، لا، هذا سيكون...
إذا تكلّم مع مطورين عقاريين أو أصحاب الأراضي إذا راح يأخذ فرع
لا يقول: ما يقدر، لأن في النهاية هذا ما راح يعطيني...
مساحة كافية للواجهة مثلًا وللا؟
ما تقدر تعطيني ثلاث مكائن، فصاروا كلهم يتكلمون نفس اللغة
فطلعنا بمعيار واحد تقريبًا من سنتين
فصار خلاص أي فرع احنا راح نتوسع فيه لازم تكون موجودة
مع أن أحيانًا تجينا مواقع مميزة في شوارع احنا نبيها
لكن بحكم أن المساحة ما قاعد تعطيني نفس اللي احنا نحتاجها
لا، نلغي الموضوع
حلو، الحين، ما شاء الله، نتكلم عن ثلاثة وأربعين فرع صح؟
ثلاثة وأربعين فرع ما قفلتوا ولا فرع، وقاعدين تكبرون وتنمون
بالمقابل أشوف في مقاهي ومطاعم كثير قاعدة تطلع من السوق حاليًّا
وفي شكاوى مستمرة في تويتر يوميًّا
سواءً على الغرامات أو سواءً على السوق نفسه
وأنا أشوف اللوم أكثر شيء يقع على السوق
أن كيف سلوك العملاء اختلف؟
يمكن الظروف الاقتصادية أثرت، أكيد أثرت على الكل
فودّي أعرف أيش تعتقد أبرز المشاكل اللي صايرة في السوق الآن؟
اللي تخلي الناس مو قادرين يكبرون وينمون زي ما أنتم قاعدين تسوون
توفيق رب العالمين أولًا وأخيرًا في موضوع
أن العلامة التجارية ينجح أو يقفل أو يفشل
والله يعوّض على اللي قفلوا، ويرزقهم، إن شاء الله
سواءً في نفس المجال أو مجالات ثانية
لكن هذا رأيي الشخصي للأمانة، أنا أعطيها ثلاثة أسباب
السبب الأول: العميل ما يلاحظ قيمة مُضافَة مختلفة
في العلامة التجارية اللي هو رايح له عن البقية
أعطيك على سبيل المثال، يمكن قلته قبل شوي
اللي هو المقاهي المختصة
المقاهي المختصة وصلت على قولتهم ذروتها
في 2015 و2016 و2017 وقتها تفتح أي قهوة مختصة
أنت راح تنجح
الآن تفتح أي قهوة مختصة، أنت راح تتعب في المنافسة
ما أقول لك: راح تفشل، بس نسبة نجاحك يمكن ما تتجاوز 10% أو 20%
عكس قبل كم سنة، ليش؟
لأن صارت الخيارات كثيرة بالنسبة للعميل، فما في قيمة مضافَة
طيب أنا ليش أروح العلامة التجارية ألف؟
وما أروح العلامة التجارية باء؟
هم أتوقع القدامى هم اللي قدروا يكوّنون لأنفسهم اسم، ويصيرون بارزين
«خطوة جمل» و«إكسير البن» الجماعة هؤلاء كلهم اللي بدأوا من البداية
هم اللي يمكن صاروا مميزين، الباقيين صاروا مجرد قهوة مختصة
صحيح، وطلعت للأمانة علامات تجارية خلال السنتين الماضية ونجحت
لكن الفكرة أنك نسبة النجاح، بعد توفيق رب العالمين، ما أشوفها زي أول
أوّل كان لا، أنك تفتح قهوة مختصة في قيمة مضافَة
أنا شايف كيف العملية، وشايف جودة المنتج
الآن تفتح قهوة مختصة بجودة خليني أقول لك: ممكن تصل لممتازة
مو بالضرورة أنك تنجح، عكس أول
وبجيك فيها سالفة المنتجات هذه، بس أيش السبب الثاني؟
السبب الثاني التغيّر في السوق من عدة جهات
تغّير في سلوك العميل
العميل احتياجاته ومطالباته سواءً في المنتجات والخدمات تختلف
أذكر على قولتهم، قصة بسيطة
في 2014، أخذت فصل في أمريكا لمدة عشرة أسابيع
وأذكر كان بداية إنستقرام في 2012
وكان إنستقرام عندي، وأنا كنت أدرس في أمريكا
كله في علامة تجارية كريب معروف
كريب؟
كريب معروف طلع وقتها
لدرجة...
في السعودية هنا؟
إيه، في السعودية فتح في الشرقية، وبعدين توسع في الرياض
ما أدري إذا في بجدة ولا لا، بس بدأت العلامة التجارية
لدرجة تخيل أني قاعد أقول: متى أرجع السعودية؟
عشان أروح أجرب العلامة التجارية هذه
حتى أذكر في نفس الفصل كان في سعوديين فكنت أكلمهم
يقول: إيه والله، شفناه وبالعكس متحمسين
تخيّل إنستقرام يوميًّا أشوف صور عن العلامة التجارية هذه
كريب بالطريقة الفلانية، وفي المنتج هذا وفي المنتج هذا
تخيّل أول ما وصلت المطار، وصلت بالليل، ثاني يوم رحت له
وكان زحمة وعليه، الآن العلامة التجارية هذه قفلت أغلب فروعها
ليش؟ لأن العلامة التجارية ما جددت
المنتجات هي نفسها من قبل عشر سنوات
الهوية ما تغيرت، وما شاف احتياجات العميل
في كثير من الشغلات ما طورها
فالتغيّر اللي صاير في السوق، إذا أنت كعلامة تجارية
ما واكبته بالتغيّر اللي أنت، يعني يناسب أو يتوافق مع العميل
هنا راح تتعب في موضوع المنافسة
عشان كذا كل أحد يبيع ماتشا الحين
ماتشا، منزلينه على فكرة
تدري ما ذقته للحين، يبيلي أجرب
الأمر الثاني عن موضوع التغّير اللي صاير في السوق
عندك دخول عدة جهات حكومية وهيئات
ودخلت في موضوع تشريعات القطاع
بهدف تصحيح القطاع الفترة الجاية
وكلها جاءت، عرفت إجراءات وتغييرات سريعة، وكلها في وقت قصير
فصار، أوّل يمكن بالشهر كنت تسمع تغيير في لائحة من لوائح البلدية
الآن لا، ممكن في الشهر يوصلك ثلاثة أو أربعة
واحدة من الزكاة وواحدة من وزارة الموارد البشرية
واحدة من البلديات، وواحدة من وزارة التجارة
حتى الآن هيئة السياحة ووزارة السياحة
دخلوا في موضوع قطاع المطاعم والمقاهي
بحكم أنهم يعتبروه كواحدة من أهم القطاعات اللي تخدم تجربة السائح
فهنا جاءك موضوع أن التحديثات واجد خلال فترة قصيرة
وإذا أنا ما واكبتها، ولا قدرت أني أواكبها
برضو راح تتعبني في موضوع المنافسة
فممكن بعضهم يصل حتى إلى الإغلاق
ممكن تجيك مخالفة واحدة من «إجادة»
وممكن هذا حق ربحك لمدة شهرين
«إجادة» أيش المخالفات اللي تجي منها، زي أيش مثلًا؟
مخالفات مثل في لبس الموظفين
إذا كانت في ملاحظة في موضوع مستوى النظافة
إذا كان في ملاحظة في موضوع التخزين
فهذه كلها المناطق اللي يشيكون فيها، يشيكون فيها «إجادة»
فممكن بعضها توصل 15 أو 20 ألف كمخالفة
هذه ربح فرع لمدة شهرين أو ثلاثة شهور
فهذه بالنسبة لي صارت عملية مرهقة
وزي ما قلت لك: كلها بهدف تصحيح
لكن عدم مواكبة، وعدم فهم أن هذا إجراء تصحيحي
لازم أنا أغير نموذج العمل بحيث يتواكب مع التغّيرات هذه
يتعّب في موضوع المنافسة
أيش السبب الثالث؟
السبب الثالث قلت لك إياه، تذبذب الجودة
إذا العميل راح فرع، وجرب المنتج، وراح فرع ثاني
وحس المنتج مختلف، هذه بداية السقوط
أو حتى رجع بكرة بنفس الطريقة
أو حتى الفترة الزمنية، خليني أقول لك: الشاورما اللي جربتها اليوم
تختلف عن الشاورما اللي جربتها الأسبوع الماضي
وللا قبل ثلاث شهور، هذه برضو بداية النهاية
أنت تشوف سبب خروج المقاهي والمطاعم من السوق هم ثلاث أسباب
هي أول شيء: أن ما عندهم شيء يميزهم
الشيء الثاني: التحديات اللي تصير في
الإجراءات والتغييرات اللي تصير
والسبب الثالث: ضبط الجودة
ممكن السبب الثاني اللي هو التغيرات الي تصير في السوق
أذكر قابلت شيف أسس مطعم، وقفّل الآن
كان يقول لي: قبل عشر سنوات أنت تسوي منتج زين، أنت راح تمشي
الآن يقول: العملية تغيرت، الآن أخش في موضوع
لازم يكون عندي فريق تقني جاهز على موضوع نقاط البيع
وعلى موضوع الربط مع البنوك
على موضوع الربط، يسمونه الدمج مع تطبيقات التوصيل
لازم يكون في تحليل البيانات، فالموضوع هذا تغير الآن
فإذا عدم مواكبة للتغيّر في الجانب التقني والتطور هذا
راح برضو يتعّب في موضوع المنافسة
بالإضافة زي ما تعرف وكثير يعرفون
موضوع دخول تطبيقات التوصيل
غيّر نماذج العمل أو الربحية للشركات
فصار الآن في جزء كبير إذا كان الشركة تعتمد 50%
أو 60% أو 70% من مبيعاتها عن طريق التطبيقات
وهي ما غيّرت نموذج العمل راح يتعبها بشكل كبير
حلو، أتوقع هذه فرصة جيّدة لنتكلم عن تطبيقات التوصيل
من ناحية أول شيء، كيف أثرهم على نموذج العمل عندكم؟
وأيش تحتاج تغيّر في نموذج العمل عشان تصير متوافق
مع تطبيقات التوصيل والنسب اللي تأخذها؟
والشيء ثاني، كيف تجربتكم مع تطبيق التوصيل الخاص فيكم؟
فخلنا نركز على النقطة الأولى، أولًا
طيب، اعتماديّتنا على تطبيقات التوصيل أمانة تكاد تكون لا تذكر
معقولة؟ أغلب السوق، يقول لك: والله أنا 50% من طلبات
لا، احنا زمان اشتغلنا، خليني بس أنا جاي من تطبيق التوصيل
جاي من القصيم
ما ودي أكون على قولتهم متحيز قدر ما أكون، إن شاء الله، محايد
لكن أهميتها ما أحد يختلف عليها
ساعدت موضوع أن عملية الطلب تكون أريح للعملاء
أنت جالس في البيت، بضغطة كم زر الطلب يكون عندك
ساعدت بشكل كبير على موضوع جودة الحياة الموجودة في السعودية
فأهميتها ما أحد يختلف عليها
لكن نموذج العمل اللي تشتغل فيه
هل يتواكب مع نموذج العمل اللي تشتغل فيه المطاعم؟
ما أعتقد
ليش؟
وأعتقد كثير من المطاعم اشتغلت على موضوع
تكبير حصة تطبيقات التوصيل وتورطت
كثير من المطاعم يقولون: تمثل تطبيقات التوصيل 70%
إذا صار في أي خلل تقني في تطبيق التوصيل
راحت المبيعات
خلاص، هدف المبيعات راح ذاك اليوم ،وراح يأثر عليه
وراح يأخذ إجراء تصحيحي على الموضوع هذا
فبعضهم كبّر على قولتهم لقمة تطبيقات التوصيل عنده
عندنا في «هاف مليون» لا
احنا ما نسوي عروض مع تطبيقات التوصيل
من آخر مرة يمكن من ثلاث سنوات، ما نسوي أبدًا عروض
وبالإضافة لاحظنا شيء مع توسُّعنا في فروع طلبات السيارات
قل عندنا نسبة تطبيقات التوصيل، بشكل واضح
لأن العميل صار عنده خيار
يا أخي أنا ممكن أمر في ثلاث أو أربع دقائق
أخذ الطلب اللي أحتاجه بدل أن أطلب ورسوم توصيل ويتأخر علي
أطلب، وأنا رايح الدوام
فلاحظنا أن هذا قلل عندنا بشكل كبير
للأمانة كل تطبيقات التوصيل قطعناها
اليوم ما تأثرنا، بشكل...
خليني أقول لك: ما يمثل حتى 5% من مبيعاتنا
معقولة؟ يا أخي قليلة مرة 5%
ما أثر بشكل كبير لأن صراحةً...
زي ما قلت لك: وجودها مهم مو معناته أن احنا راح نشيلها
قدر ما أن في كثير مثلًا من العوائل اللي ما عنده سيارة
وللا اللي يحتاجون وقت الجمعات الصناديق الموجودة عندنا
فيحتاج أنها تكون عن طريق تطبيقات التوصيل
فهي خيار مريح وفرناه للعميل
بس حلوة فكرة أنك ما تروّج أو على الأقل ما تروّج بشكل مستمر
مع التطبيقات عشان ما تكبّر حصتها
خليني أقول لك: هذا احنا تداركناه للأمانة من البداية
بحيث أن حصة تطبيقات التوصيل
زي ما قلت لك: وجودها مهم لكن ما تأثر بشكل كبير بالنسبة لنا
نجي على تطبيق «هاف مليون»
برأيك الشخصي، كم تشوف النسبة اللي يأخذها تطبيق التوصيل
من إجمالي مبيعاتك اللي إذا تجاوزها فأنت بمرحلة خطر؟
الأمر يختلف من نشاط لنشاط
خلينا نقول: على المقاهي
والله بالنسبة لي أقول...
مو النسبة اللي يأخذها من إجمالي المبيعات
لا، عارف، أرى كلما قلّت كلما كان أفضل
أعتقد إذا زادت عن 15% أو 20% فهذا مؤشر غير جيّد
من جميع التطبيقات؟
إيه
ونسبة اللي يأخذونها من الطلب الواحد، كيف تتعامل معها؟
لأن فيه افتراض أن المقاهي حتى المطاعم نفس الشيء
غالبًا أي أحد خارج القطاع هذا، سواءً من تطبيقات التوصيل أو غيره
أحيانًا يفترضون أن هوامشهم عالية ما عليك
شوف كم يدخلون؟ فخلينا نأخذ منها شوي
فكيف يغيّر هذا في نموذج العمل عندك في التسعير
وفي بناء تركيبة المنتج والأشياء هذه كلها؟
نسبة تطبيقات التوصيل بالنسبة لنا
ما هو والله عشان احنا نُصنَّف كمقهى
فبيرفع علينا النسبة
لا، احنا ماشيين في نفس السوق
بس أن أيش تحتاج تعدل عندك بحيث
أن ما تكون التطبيقات تأكل من ربحك بشكل كبير؟
أقول لك: الآن اللي صار كثير من المطاعم والمقاهي رفعوا السعر
في تطبيقات التوصيل عشان تطلع العملية مجدية بالنسبة له
فأتوقع هذا واحد من أهم الإجراءات اللي يتم توصيلها
وهنا بنخش في موضوع المقارنات
أنا لقيت سعركم في تطبيق إكس يختلف عن تطبيق واي
فأعتقد رفع السعر...
وتسوونه هذه أنتم؟
هذه احنا مسوينها إيه
ترفعونه في تطبيق التوصيل؟
إيه، احنا رافعين في تطبيقات التوصيل
عشان تعوضون النسبة هذه اللي تروح
وهل في منتجات، أنا شفت بعض المطاعم مثلًا
يقول لك: المنتجات اللي سعرها عالي مثل الصناديق والأشياء هذه
ما يحطها في التطبيق، لأنهم سيأكلون أبو...
يأكلون جزء كبير منهم
لا، احنا كل المنتجات موجودة
كل المنتجات موجودة، حلو
أنتم ترفعون الأسعار، والطق يجي على التطبيق
لا، خليني أنا أعطيك إياها
احنا موفرين للعميل فروع بمساحة
خلني أقول: مساحة الأرض توصل من 900 إلى 1500
فاحنا مستثمرين في موضوع الموقع
مستثمرين في الديكور وتصميم الفرع
وكل فرع عندنا كواجهات تختلف من فرع لفرع
عشان نحسّن في موضوع تجربة العميل
مستثمرين في موضوع أن فروعنا تكون فيها طلبات سيارات
وهذه تكلفتها أكثر من فروع اللي ما هي طلبات سيارات
مستثمرين في موضوع...
بس ما أتصور واجد يجون يتكّون، صح؟
لا، في، يعتمد صراحةً على حسب المكان وعلى حسب...
فكل هذا احنا مستثمرين فيه
فالعميل بالنسبة له، يجي الفرع ما يتغير عليه السعر
خلينا نتكلم عن موضوع السعر دامك ذكرت الموضوع
سعر اللاتيه في «هاف مليون» من يوم ما تأسس إلى اليوم ما تغيّر
مع أنه مر...
حجمه صغر ولا؟
لا هو نفس الحجم ونفس الكوب، بس تغيرت هوية، هو بس نفس الحجم
عشرة ريال وكان شامل الضريبة يوم كانت الضريبة 5%
مع زيادة الضريبة 15% برضو «هاف مليون» تحمّل الضريبة
برضو مع تغير أسعار المواد الخام وسلاسل الإمداد
خصوصًا بعد فترة كورونا، واللي مرت على الجميع
موضوع تغيير السعر، عرفت اللي هو ما يتم مناقشته
في بعض العلامات التجارية يقولوا: والله احنا أثرنا كذا؛ فبنرفع السعر
ليش إذا السوق كله قاعد يرفع، فرصة؟
هذا غير قابل النقاش بالنسبة لنا
لأنه واحدة من القيم اللي احنا نزعم أن نعطيها العميل
اللي هو موضوع أن الأسعار تكون في متناول أيدي الجميع
فاحنا نقول: رفعنا سعرنا في التطبيقات
لأنه يأخذ هوامش كبيرة
وزي ما قلت لك: احنا أسعارنا في متناول أيدي الجميع، وموجودة بفروعنا
ما غيرنا سعرنا من يوم ما بدأنا...
فأنت تحملت الضريبة
وتحملت الأشياء الإضافية اللي جاءت مع مرور الوقت
بالضبط
ارتفاعات المواد الخام
بس قلت: خلاص نسبة التطبيقات كبيرة أحتاج أرفعها
ما رفعنا شيء كبير، شيء بسيط
لكن بالنسبة للعميل ما تغير سعر المنتج بالنسبة له
العميل اللي كان موجود في «هاف مليون» في 2018
راح يشوف نفس أسعارنا الآن
حتى المنتجات الجديدة احنا ننزلها ما ننزلها بأسعار عالية
كلها في متناول أيدي الجميع
تجربتكم في تطبيقكم الخاص للتوصيل أو حتى الاستلام
هل أيضًا بما أنكم موفرين خدمة السيارات
معناته أن حتى تطبيقكم ما يجيب لكم طلبات كثيرة؟
إلّا، لا عندنا التطبيق الخاص في «هاف مليون»
بس ما فيه توصيل، بس استلام من الفرع
وحدة من الـ... طلّعناها مو عشان والله يكون عندنا تطبيق وشكله حلو
قدر ما أنه أحد الخيارات اللي شعرنا أنها مناسبة للعميل
أن يطلب ويستلم من الفرع بدال ما يستنى إذا كان مستعجل
يطلب وخلال عشر دقائق يروح الفرع، ويستلم طلبه
فهنا تتكلم على...
وفرناه بالنسبة له، تمثل نسبة للأمانة...
تطبيق «هاف مليون» بالنسبة لنا كنسبتها من المبيعات
أكثر من تطبيقات التوصيل
وهل هي نسبة كبيرة؟
نسبة ممتازة، أنا أقول لك: أكثر من تطبيقات التوصيل
أكثر من 5% المفروض؟
إيه، أكثر من 5%
فيصير العميل يقدر حتى بتوصيل سيارة يطلب الطلب ويستلمه
بس أنا أعتقد أن عندكم ميزة هنا تنجّح تطبيقكم غصب
اللي هي فكرة أن انتشار الفروع أول شيء
والمنتج نفسه منتج يوميًّا يستهلكه الواحد
عكس، أنا أشوف بتجربة بعض المطاعم تكون ما هي جيّدة
لأنه يبيع لك منتج ما تشتهيه إلا مرة كل شهر
صحيح
ما راح تستخدم التطبيق
هو يسمونه التردد أن العميل يجيك دائم ودائم
بحكم طبيعة النشاط، عميل ممكن يجي لي
ممكن بعض العملاء حتى يجينا من الملاحظات
يقول: أنا عميلكم أطلب من التطبيق مرتين أو ثلاث مرات في اليوم
الصباح وبعد الدوام، وممكن أجيكم بالليل برضو، وكلها عن طريق التطبيق
فهذا برضو أكيد عامل مهم ومساعد في موضوع زيادة حصة
تطبيق «هاف مليون» من إجمالي المبيعات
نتكلم الحين على موضوع المنتجات
أنت تكلمت عن أن أحد أسباب المقاهي أنها تفشل
لأنها لا ما عندها شيء يميّزها مقارنة بالمقاهي الثانية
أيش تعتقد يميزكم اليوم؟
خلينا نرجع إلى القيمة اللي احنا نوفرها للعميل هي ثلاث قيم
قيمة جودة المنتجات
وقيمة الأسعار في متناول أيدي الجميع
والقيمة الثالثة هي تجربة العميل
حرصنا دائمًا أن تجربة العميل تكون مميزة
اللي يمر فروع «هاف مليون» أو يأخذ منتج من «هاف مليون»
فهذه هي القيم اللي احنا بالنسبة لنا
كل الشغل اللي قاعد يصير في الشركة
وكل العمليات تصب في واحدة من القيم هذه
حلو، بس الآن كيف تطورون منتجاتكم عشان تضمنون
أنها تكون على الأقل فيه اختلاف عن السوق وأن تكون مميزة؟
في بداية كل سنة يكون عندنا خطة منتجات راح نطلقها خلال السنة هذه
منها الأشياء الموسمية، أتصور صيف وشتاء؟
إيه منها الأشياء الموسمية
لأن المنتجات مربوطة أيضًا في التسويق
فخطوة التسويق تكون معتمدة على المنتجات اللي احنا راح نطلقها
فبس بالبداية يجي موضوع أن أنا في الصيف راح أنزل منتج
خليني أقول لك: سيكون عندي موهيتو وشاي مثلج
ومثلجات بالنكهة الفلانية
وفي الشتاء سيكون عندي مشروب الشتاء هذا
فيصير خلاص من بداية السنة
ويصير الشغل كله خلال طول السنة
على موضوع تجارب المنتج وعلى موضوع التكلفة
على موضوع نجرّب المورّدين
شلون تقرر أنك تختار المنتجات هذه؟
لأن في برضو مخاطرة أنك تختار شيء
وتطلع هبّة فجأة في الصيف تكون أنت طالع منها أساسًا
معك، نشوف صراحةً، كمقارنة في السوق، أيش المنتج...
خليني أقول لك: الماتشا، احنا نزلنا الحين الماتشا
الماتشا الآن صار بالنسبة للسوق منتج مطلوب
والعميل دائمًا، جاءنا أكثر من عميل يمكن خلال الفترة من سنة تقريبًا
يتكلم متى تنزلون ماتشا، وليش ما تنزلون ماتشا؟
فسمعنا لصوت العميل ففعلًا أخذناه بالاعتبار في خطة المنتجات
وهو إذا جاءك في وسط السنة، تقول له: السنة الجاية أحطه؟
إذا كان في مساحة، وممكن نطلع فيه بشكل أسرع
لا، ممكن نطلع فيه في نفس السنة
حلو
لكن دائمًا أغلب المنتجات تكون مُخطَّط لها من ست إلى تسعة شهور
لأنها تمر صراحة في عمليات كثيرة
أحيانًا في منتجات وقفناها، ما نزلناها
بحكم أن المورّد احنا مو واثقين فيه
في موضوع توفير المنتج أو موضوع الأسعار، فوقفنا المنتج نفسه
مع أن المنتج مطلوب، لكن في النهاية ما أبي أعطي شيء للعميل
وفي النهاية يلقاه مقطوع
وللا أعطي شيء للعميل وفي النهاية المورّد يغيّر في موضوع الجودة
المورد يورد لك أحد المكونات
المواد الخام
زي أيش؟
الشراب المركّز أو المنتج نفسه تُصنَّف كلها كمواد خام
أي مادة في المنتج
المورّد يكون ما يقدر يوردها لك باعتمادية عالية، فتقول...
بالضبط
يا راح أدوّر بديل وللا بوقّف
بالضبط، برضو حريصين أن على قولتهم في التكلفة
في البداية تكون التكلفة نازلة بشكل كبير عشان نقدر ننزل المنتج
أنا راح أجيك الحين بالتكلفة بس خلينا ودي أقفل موضوع المنتج
الآن أيش الأسباب الثانية اللي تخليك توقف منتج؟
ما أوقف المنتج، أوقف أن المنتج ينزل
إيه، توقف المنتج ينزل
إيه، مو منتج عندي أوقفه
قدر ما أن عندي منتج، الحين جربناه
قصدك أنه في طور اختبار المنتج هذا، شفت مشاكله؟
في تطوير المنتج لاحظنا أنه تشغيليًّا سيكون متعب
تشغيليًّا ممكن يؤثر عليّ على سرعة الطلبات
فيكون مثلًا إعداده بطيء، على سبيل المثال
هذا سيكون برة المعادلة
طيب ما قد طلعت منتج نزل للسوق؟
تقول: خلاص، هذا شكله ما عجب الناس، أسحبه مرة ثانية
إيه، عادي هذا طبيعي، المنتجات الموسمية
في منتجات تكون مناسبة مثلًا في فترة فلانية
فيكون موجود، وبعدين ينشال عادي
فاحنا في مرونة في الموضوع
لأننا حريصين أن لائحة الاختيارات ما تكون كبيرة
حريصين أن لائحة الاختيارات ما تكون مشتتة للعميل، ويكون واضح
حتى إذا نزلنا مثلًا إذا نزلنا مثلجات
ما نزلنا بأربع أو خمس أنواع، نزلنا بنوعين
يوم نزلنا شاي مثلج، نوع واحد
يوم نزلنا في الموهيتو، ما تتجاوز ثلاثة أنواع
فحريصين أن ما يكون في تشتت للعميل
وأن العميل إذا راح «هاف مليون»
وجرّب أي صنف من الأصناف الموجودة
في لائحة الاختيارات، فبإذن الله، يكون واحدة
من أفضل المنتجات الموجودة
التسعير، أنا كشخص من برة على الأقل
أجي أشوف لائحة الاختيارات عندكم، فيه أشياء مثلًا
أشوف القهوة سعرها منطقي جدًّا، تكون منخفضة
ما أذكر بالضبط الأسعار عندكم بس أذكر انطباعي عنها
أن القهوة تكون مثلًا سعرها معقول
بس بعدين نشوف المثلجات سعرها فوق
نشوف السندويشات يمكن أغلى، سواءً الصغيرة أو الكبيرة
فهل هذه سياسة التسعير، أن تصيد العميل من القهوة
اللي يجيك بشكل مستمر؟
لا، واحدة من أهم قيمنا أن تكون المنتجات
تكون بمتناول أيدي الجميع
فهذا سواءً على القهوة، وعلى أي منتج ينزل
بس لازم تربح بمكان، ما أنت...
ليش أتصور عندك أن احنا...
احنا ما نناظر أننا رخيصين
يعني ما بعت قهوة بريال وريالين
أكيد
في النهاية احنا أسعارنا للأمانة أشوفها منطقية
تقول: لا أنك قاعد تزيد وقاعد تتحمل الضريبة
وتتحمل المتغيرات كلها
عشان كذا قلت لك: هذا يعطي ضغط كبير على فريق المشتريات
وعلى فريق التشغيل وعلى موضوع الهدر
بحيث يكون منخفض بشكل كبير
بحيث تعطيه أريحية أن احنا نقدر نربح من المنتج
فأنت فعليًّا تحاول تخفض التكاليف أكثر من أنك تحاول تزيد الأرباح بشكل سريع
بالضبط، ولا يتغير جودة المواد الخام
ما جينا نشوف بديل في مواد الخام، لكن الطعم يتغير
ونقول: لا والله، هذا ممكن العميل ما يلاحظه
أنا أقول لك: في موضوعين ما يتم نقاشهم
موضوع تغيّر الأسعار وموضوع جودة المواد الخام
يا أخي هذا جودته أقل بس راح نوفر كذا
ما فيه، هذا ما يتم نقاشه في الشركة عندنا
خارج السياق اللي احنا نتكلم فيه
وفي سلسة الإمداد، هل قررتم أن تدخلون فيها
بحيث تقولون: أن القهوة احنا سنبدأ بتحميصها أو نبدأ باستيرادها؟
فعلًا، احنا من بداية المشروع احنا نحمّص
هذا أنتم تسوونه؟
إيه، فعشان كذا نتأكد في موضوع الجودة
ونتأكد في موضوع أنه يواكب مع احتياج الفروع اللي احنا نحتاجه
برضو راح يساعدنا في موضوع التكلفة
بس ما تستوردوا من المزارع، مثلًا تروحون وتأخذون من مورّد؟
لا، من المزارع
داخلين في السلسلة من البداية؟
كلما كان دخولك في السلسلة بشكل أكبر
كلما أعطاك أوفر في موضوع المنتج
لكن مو كل الشركات ومو كل العلامات التجارية
تقدر تخش في موضوع السلسلة كاملة
لأنك تحتاج برضو مبيعات، وللا ما تدخل وأنت عندك فرع واحد
أروح أستورد وأجي
بالضبط
في أي منتج ثاني سويت فيه نفس الشيء، مخبوزات؟
قلت: والله بسوي مخبز ولا بسوي...؟
احنا داخلين في موضوع المخبوزات
احنا نتكلم، حاليًّا تحت إنشاء ثلاث مصانع
مصانع أيش؟
التحميص عندنا، فداخلين الحين في موضوع التحميص
بحيث أن حتى السعة الإنتاجية للمحمصة تكون أكبر
وبرضو موضوع المخبوزات
حاليًّا احنا عندنا مصنع المخبوزات والحلا الخاص فينا
وفي مصنع ثالث غذائي برضو شغّالين عليه على بعض المنتجات
بحيث أن احنا فعلًا نتأكد من موضوع الجودة، ونتأكد موضوع الأسعار
نتأكد من موضوع أنه المصانع هذه تقدر توفر الاحتياج
اللي احنا نحتاجه بالفروع، على حسب ما زاد الطلب عليها
حلو، ما أبي أدخل بموضوع المصانع والأمور هذه والمطابخ المركزية
لأن أتصور أي أحد يصير عنده عدد فروع كبيرة
أساسًا يتوجّه بشكل طبيعي للموضوع هذا
فخلينا ننتقل الآن لجانب التسويق
تكلمنا يمكن عن رعاية الشباب، وتجربتكم في البداية
فما أبي أرجع أكررها ثاني مرة
في أشياء تسويقية ثانية أشوف تسوونها
ما أدري صراحةً هي بس عشان الناس يتكلمون عنها؟
وللا أنه شيء صملتوا عليه؟
زي مسألة أنكم تسوون فرع في البحر
إيه
أيش فكرتها هذه؟ بالأخير قارب يبيع مشروبات مثلجة
أيش الفكرة في الموضوع؟
ممتاز، هي...، القارب لها أكثر من بُعد
اللي هي يسمونها «هاف مليون مليون بوتز»
طلعنا فيه مرتين، الصيف الماضي
طلعنا فيه في جدة في منطقة اسمها بياضة، معروفة
كل حقين جدة يروحون لها خلال إجازات نهاية الاسبوع
وفيه برضو السنة هذه
الفكرة منها يُسمَّى
تموضع العلامة التجارية
تموضع العلامة التجارية، وتكون موجودة...
واحنا قطعنا وعد داخليًّا أن علامة «هاف مليون» التجارية
يكون موجود حيث يتواجد الناس
فطلعنا بفكرة ابتكارية موجودة هناك
وبالعكس ما كان وجودها...
كنا نعرف أنها تسويق بشكل كبير
ترويج للعلامة التجارية أكثر من أنه فرع
لكن فعلًا في احتياج هناك في المنطقة
فشفنا برضو حتى بعدما طلعنا احنا
في كذا علامة تجارية طلع في نفس الفكرة
بس ما سوّيت فرعك هو
كثر ما أنه صارت المشروبات موجودة على القارب، مثلجة
صحيح
بحيث أنك توصلها...
الناس تيجيها أو نوصلها لها
ما في شي يتسوّى في القارب نفسه؟
لا، ما في
عشان نركز في موضوع الجودة فما قدرنا نسويها
أيضًا دخلتم أنتم برعاية موسم الرياض؟
دخلنا في رعاية موسم الرياض، موسم 2021
موسم 2021 خصوصًا بعد كورونا
كان فيه تعطّش كبير على موضوع الترفيه بشكل كبير في السعودية
ووفقنا الله، أن دخلنا في موضوع رعاية الموسم
كان لمدة تقريبًا ستة شهور
كان عندكم فرع بعد بالـ...؟
إيه، عندنا فرع في البوليفارد
وبرضو في «الونترلاند» كان عندنا فرع
وبرضو في «الكومبات فيلد» وقتها يوم كان موجود كان عندنا فرع
فتواجدنا في ثلاث مناطق
أداءه كيف كان مقارنة بباقي الفروع؟
أداء أيش؟
أداء الفرع حق «هاف مليون» في البوليفارد مثلًا
ممتاز، للأمانة موسم 2021 كان الكل شاهد عليه
كيف كان ناجح، وكيف أن الموسم من بدايته
بدأ تقريبًا في نوفمبر إلى فبراير
كان فيه زوّار ما يوقفون على كثير من الـ...
بس ليش حاصرها بالفترة تلك، بعدها ما كملتوا؟
الموسم هو كان هو بالفترة هذه بس
الموسم كان تقريبًا من نوفمبر إلى فبراير
أنت قصدك إلى فبراير الـ...؟
لا، من نوفمبر 2021 إلى فبراير 2022
إيه بس قصدي، ما كملتوا بعدها، موسم الرياض، الموسم اللي بعده؟
لا ما كملناه، كان عندنا أكثر من نشاط ثاني احنا شغالين عليه
فما مشينا في الموضوع الرعاية للموسم الثاني
أيش سبب اهتمامكم بتطوير المنتجات
زي ورق البلوت والأكواب الجديدة هذه؟
رخيصة مرة كانت، كم كان سعرها؟
الكوب الحديد ذا ستانلس ستيل
إيه أربعة وعشرين ريال
اللي يحفظ الحرارة، ما عمري دخلت مقهى بحياتي
إلا ويبيعوه بخمسة وسبعين
وشامل قهوة؟
أول مرة تعبيه قهوة ببلاش
إيه أول مرة يكون القهوة ببلاش، هنا جينا...
يطلع عليكم بخسارة فعليًّا
نجي هنا على موضوع ورق «البلوت»
احنا ما نناظر «هاف مليون» كمقهى
أو يمكن بعض الناس يقولون: يا أخي الكلام هذا نظري
أناظره كأسلوب حياة
فعلًا كأسلوب حياة
فموضوع ورق «البلوت» وموضوع الأكواب اللي تحفظ الحرارة
وكثير من المنتجات اللي راح ننزل فيها خلال الفترة الجاية أنها فعلًا
كيف أننا نكون متواجدين معك في أغلب نشاطك اليومي؟
على أساس الناس يشوفونه
واحد من الشباب يوم نزلنا في موضوع الأكواب الحرارية
واحد يقول لي: من الشركات المعروفة في «الدائري»
يقول: كل الشركة عندنا وكل موظفين الشركة دخلوا ثاني يوم
معهم كوب «هاف مليون»
فهذا بالنسبة لي أنا موجود مو بس بالفروع
أنا متواجد حتى في المكاتب، وأنا موجود حتى في الأندية
وأنا موجود حتى في البيوت
وفي السيارة يكون أحيانًا الأكواب موجودة
فكان هدف «هاف مليون» يكون قريب من الناس
فعشان كذا طلعنا في المنتجات هذه
فهو حتى لو أنت خسران على مستوى الكوب وللا على مستوى الورق
أنا ما أدري، كم كنتوا تبيعونه؟
بس أنك تأخذه كتكلفة تسويقية
أن أنا آخذ الكوب رخيص...
تقدر تعتبره إيه
بالقهوة حقته بأربع وعشرين أو خمسة وعشرين ريال
بس في النهاية إذا استخدمته باستمرار
فالعلامة التجارية حقتي ستكون موجودة في كل مكان
في موضوع مهم له علاقة في إدارة الفروع والمبيعات والأمور هذه كلها
اللي هو التوظيف، كيف تجيب الموظفين هؤلاء؟
كيف تدربهم وتأهلهم؟
فكم عدد موظفينكم اليوم وصل؟
الحين عدّينا 1200
هذا شامل الفروع والإدارة مع بعض؟
صحيح
التوظيف الآن، كم السعودين يمثلون كم؟
شوف تزيد وتنقص على 50% تقريبًا
بس ما يقارب 50% عدد نسبة الموظفين السعوديين
بس من المعروف أن القطاع سواءً المقاهي أو المطاعم
من القطاعات اللي فيها نسبة دوران عالية في الموظفين
صح
فهل أنتم ماشيين نفس نسبة الدوران اللي في السوق؟
وللا تحافظون عليهم بشكل...
خليني أقسم لك هنا على موضوع توظيف فريق الفروع
وتوظيف الفريق الإداري
توظيف فريق الفروع، نسبة من كل عشرة نقابلهم كمرشحين
نختار منهم اثنين بس
ليش؟
ما أقول لك: أن من كل عشرة نقابلهم نبي اثنين
قدر ما أنه فعلًا احنا حريصين...
كمعدل فقط
حريصين اللي يمثّل العلامة التجارية
ودائمًا أقول لهم إذا اجتمعت مع فريق العمل
سواءً كان كاشير وللا صانع قهوة، وللا عامل نظافة في الفرع
أقول له: العميل ما راح يعرف صهيب
ما راح يعرف مدير التشغيل
ما راح يقابل مدير التسويق، راح يقابلك أنت وأنت وأنت
فأنت بالنسبة له تمثّل العلامة التجارية
فحريصين أن موضوع اختيار الموظفين يكون بجودة عالية
وحريصين حتى كيف الأسلوب، وكيف التعامل؟
والحمد لله، الآن وصلنا...
التعليقات اللي تجينا من العملاء
الإيجابية أكثر بكثير من التعليقات السلبية
بس كيف تضمن؟
أنت بالنهاية راح تجيب واحد سواءً يعد قهوة وللا يبيع
صح، هذه أول خطوة، التوظيف والاختيار
وعندنا معايير على موضوع الاختيار
بس هو موضوع الاختيار، كيف تضمن واحد أسلوبه زين؟
في النهاية خليني أقول لك: توفيق
في النهاية ممكن بالمقابلة يكون ممتاز، لكن بعدين ما يطلع بالشكل الجيّد
فهذا قصدي
إذا أنت راح تأخذه على وظيفة تعتبر بسيطة من ناحية الإمكانيات
فما في شي تفلتر عليه فعليًّا، أيش راح تفلتر عليه؟
طريقة الكلام والأسلوب
وإذا كان عنده خبرات في نفس المجال وللا لا
ففي لها أكثر من معيار
هذه كاختيار
خلني أعطيك إياها
بس مو بالضرورة أنه هذا 100% معناته إذا اخترناه صح
معناته هذا راح يكون موجود، لا، ممكن ...
أكيد
في النهاية بشر، ما أحد يخلو من أي خطأ
بس نسبة نجاحة عالية أنه يعطيني تجربة عميل مميزة
نجي للمرحلة الثانية مرحلة التدريب
فعندنا احنا مركز تدريب
ما في أي عضو من أعضاء فريق «هاف مليون» يعمل بالفرع
إلا يمر على مركز تدريب، ويخش برنامج على الثلاث وظائف اللي قلتها
أيش الثلاثة وظائف؟
كاشير وصانع قهوة وعامل نظافة
أيش تدرب في كل واحد فيهم؟ عامل النظافة بعد؟
حتى عمال النظافة اللي عندنا يمرون ببرنامج تدريبي
لحظة إذا جاء مثلًا سعودي يبي يشتغل
يمر على الثلاثة برامج هذه كلها؟
لا، عندنا ثلاثة وظائف، بالفرع راح تلقى ثلاثة وظائف
بالإضافة لمدير الفرع، وتحت مدير الفرع في قائد فريق
اللي هو يمسك المناوبة
سواءً الفترة الصباحية أو المسائية
فأغلب السعوديين يخشون يا كاشير أو صانع قهوة
وفي بعض الجاليات الآسيوية هم يكونون مثلًا يا يكون صانع قهوة
أو عمال نظافة في الفرع
فكلهم يمرون في برنامج تدريب لمدة أسبوع
يوصل إلى ثلاثة أسابيع خلال، هو مو بس برنامج تدريب
قدر أنه في نهاية التدريب في اختبار
فبعضهم ما يجتاز الاختبار
أيش يتعلم؟ كاشير مثلًا
صانع القهوة أتفهم أن راح تعلّمه شلون يسوي قهوة
بس الكاشير أيش يتعلم؟
أول شيء ندربه عن نقاط البيع، أيش المنتجات الموجودة؟
ونعطيه تفصيل عن المنتجات، لأنه هو واجهة العميل
إذا سأله عن أي منتج نحصل أن يكون مستوى معرفته بالمنتجات عالية
هذا الجانب الأول
الجانب الثاني: طريقة تعامله مع العملاء
ودائمًا أقول لهم: العملاء ما راح يجونك ملائكة
في المعصب وفي المضغوط وفي المستعجل
فكيف أنك تتعامل معه بشكل صحيح
مرحلة إذا عندنا منتج جديد، كيف أنك تسوّق له
وتقول له: عندنا منتج مميز، وتذكر تفاصيله
فهذا يمر في مرحلة تقريبًا خمسة أيام
وبعدها يصير مؤهل أنه ينزل الفرع، ويمارس عمله ككاشير
بعدين بعد ستة شهور إذا فعلًا أداؤه كان ممتاز، وجيّد مع التقييم
يخش في برنامج أن يترقى كصانع قهوة
أنتم الحين معتبرين أن صانع القهوة ترقية على الكاشير؟
لأنك تخش في تفاصيل
تحتاج مهارة أكثر
مهارة أكثر، وفي النهاية العميل راح يجرب المنتج هذا
كلهم بالنسبة للوظائف حساسة
مع أن الناس تستصغر الموضوع بس زي ما قلت لك إياه
أنا أقول لهم دائمًا: أنت واجهة العمل التجاري
العميل إذا جاء، يشوفك أنت
هذا واحد يبي يستلم طلبه، وهذا راح يسوي له إياه
إي بسوي له إياه
فكل واحد له أهميته وله دوره بشكل خاص
فيأخذ ستة شهور كاشير، وبعدين كصانع قهوة كم يشتغل؟
ممكن بعضهم سنة وبعضهم يقعد لك سنة ونص
وبعضهم سنتين
بعدين المرحلة اللي بعدها ينتقل لقائد فريق
يصير يمسك له مناوبة بالنسبة له
بعدين المرحلة اللي بعدها يصير مدير فرع
بعدين بعد مدير الفرع يصير يمسك له منطقة
يصير عنده عدة فروع يصير هو المسؤول عنها
بس هل نسبة الدوران في كل وظيفة من هذه الوظائف
عالية زي باقي السوق؟
أو لأنك تعطيه مسار واضح تشوف أنها صارت أقل النسبة
ويكملون معك؟
لا، الحمد لله، أقل بكثير من اللي في السوق
نسبة الدوران اللي عندنا، طبيعة...
بس أنا أشوف كل أحد يسوي الحركة هذه حقت اللي...
مثلًا واحد من المطاعم المشهورة جدًّا
يحط لك في الإعلان كذا، كُن مديرًا بعد سنة
وحاط لك صورة سعودي كذا لابس كرفتة فمرة...
ومع ذلك ما زال عندهم...
هنا نحتاج بس أن نوضح بشكل أكثر
مسألة أنه حط الإعلان اللي قلته
هل هو ساعد في موضوع تقليل الدوران؟
ساعد
بس هل هو حل المشكلة جذريًّا؟ لا
أيش المشكلة الجذرية؟
أنه عندك، طبيعة اللي يشتغل لك في القطاع هذا
ما هو بالسعودية بس عالميًّا
أن هذه وظائف مؤقتة، يعتبر باقيلي ستة أشهر أو سنة
ممكن سنتين كحد أقصى وبعدين...
لأن بعضهم طلاب جامعة
وبعضهم يدرس بتخصصات مختلفة جدًّا عن موضوع
الضيافة وقطاع المطاعم والمقاهي...فيتوجه التوجه هذا
فما أراها...، هو تحدي
بس كيف أنك تقلل المشكلة؟ هذا هو دور كل شركة
فشغّالين على موضوع أن كيف أن تخلي بيئة العمل مريحة؟
كيف أن تخلي المسار أوضح؟
أيش تقدر تسوي له على مستوى الفرع عشان يصير مرتاح؟
خليني أقول لك: من أهمها أن يكون تعامل مدير الفرع جيّد معاه
في مرونة في موضوع الدوام، طبعًا مرونة مو معناته تهاون
تعال وروح متى ما تبي
إيه، لا قدر من والله يختار المناوبة الصباحية
يكون له في تعاون أن يختار المناوبة هذه
للأمانة يحكمها برضو احتياج العمل
لكن هذه واحدة من الأسباب اللي تساعد
كيف تضمن أن مدير الفرع قاعد يعامل الموظفين بشكل جيّد؟
أنا شخصيًّا كنت اشتغلت في قهوة قبل كذا
وكان مدير الفرع صراحةً سيء
من بداية سنة 2023 صار تقييم مدير الفرع عندنا
نسبة منه آراء الموظفين اللي عنده
طيب إذا طلع الموظف؟
شلون طلع؟
فرضًا أنت الحين تقيّمه كل سنة صح؟
جاء في موظف، وطلع بعد ثمانية شهور يقيّم بعد وللا؟
لا، طلع خلاص
لكن أتكلم لك خلال الفترة الموجود فيها
حافز مدير الفرع نسبة منه نأخذها من التقييم والآراء
اللي تجينا من اللي تحته
من التقييم السنوي
احنا نقيّم ربعيًّا
كم؟
كل ربع يعني كل ثلاثة شهور
ما يمديه مثلًا أن يقول: شهر نوفمبر بفصل؟
لا، والعملية ما هي فصل ما فصل
قدر أنه في فريق الموارد البشرية يدخل في الموضوع
ويحقق إذا كان في أي تقييم سيء للموظفين في الفرع
فهنا دخلنا موضوع أن الموظف يقدر يقيّم مديره
وهذه تؤخذ بالاعتبار
ونشوف أيش التحديات والمشاكل الموجودة فيها
بحيث نحسّن دائمًا عندنا موضوع العملية هذه
اختيار الموظف أن الفرع يكون قريب من بيته
هذا برضو عامل كبير في موضوع استمرارية الموظف
هذه أهم ثلاث أسباب رئيسية في موضوع الاستمرارية
نجي للسبب الرابع اللي نقدر نذكره
هو موضوع أن يكون فيه مسار، فبعضهم حاب أن يكمل في الشركة
فأنا عندي مثلًا زي ما قلت لك: فريق خدمة العملاء
كلهم سعوديين جايين من الفروع
عندي فريق الجودة الآن أغلبهم جايين من الفروع
عندي في موظفين في الموارد البشرية جايين من الفروع
عندي فريق في التسويق بعضهم درس، وكان شغّال في «هاف مليون»
وكان يدرس تسويق، فيوم تخرج سوينا له مقابلة
وصار ضمن فريق التسويق
بالإضافة الحين حاليًّا عندنا خمس مدراء فروع
وأحد عشر قائد فريق
فريق التدريب ما أنساهم كلهم جاؤوا من الفروع
اللي يدربون الموظفين الجدد كلهم كانوا يا كاشير يا صانع قهوة
غير مسألة أنك تقدر توظف ناس في الإدارة
لأن هذه برضو من التحديات اللي عند كل الشركات
حلو برضو أنه ما تجيب أحد ينظّر
واحد بدأ من الصفر من عندك شايف بالضبط
كيف الشغل ماشي، وعارف المنتجات وانطباع العملاء
كل الأمور هذه، فمر على كل المراحل
بالضبط
ويصير إذا بغى يبني قرار في الإدارة يكون عارف أيش اللي صار تحته
صحيح، والمزيج للأمانة ممتاز
المزيج أنك...، في بعض الوظائف خلاص تكون موجودة بالـ..
جايين من الفروع، وهم اللي على قولتهم
بدأوا الشركة من الصفر والآن بدأوا يكبرون فيها
وإن شاء الله، يكبرون أكبر وأكبر
ومزيج أن يكون فيه خبرات موجودة برة
فالمزيج هذا ممتاز لتطوير أي منظومة
حلو، فمع كل هذه الأشياء اللي تكلمنا عنها
يبيلنا ندخل بشوية على الأرقام أكثر الحين
أذكر في الحفل السنوي اللي سويتوه
قلت أن: مبيعاتكم الظاهر توازي كم طيارة إيرباص؟
أربع طيارات
أربع طيارات، كم؟
تقريبًا، خلينا نتكلم على مثلًا السنة الماضية، مو شرط، ما أبغى رقم
أنا دائمًا أقول للضيوف: ماني هيئة الزكاة
ما أحتاج رقم دقيق، بس عشان يبين حجم العمل
لا ما راح أعطيك مبيعات السنة الماضية
لكن راح أعطيك خلينا نقول لك: من بداية مشروع «هاف مليون»
إلى اليوم تُقدّر المبيعات راح أعطيك كنطاق
تتكلم من مليار إلى مليار ونص
ما شاء الله
كإيرادات
هذه خلال كم سنة؟
خلال خمس سنوات
حلو
تقريبًا أكثر من خمس سنوات فتتكلم على...
فالإيرادات هذه كانت بالنسبة لنا
حلو، مين منافسينكم حاليًّا في السوق
اللي تعتبرونهم منافسين بشكل مباشر لكم؟
أي واحد يسوي قهوة منافس
حتى عامل الشاي حقكم قبل شوي، هذا منافس
تعطيه وضعية حق نيتفلكس اللي يقول: النوم منافس لنا
بس جد أنتم تشوفون...أو خليني أعيد صيغة السؤال
وين مكانكم بين المنافسين الآن؟
أنا خليني راح أعطيك أيش المعايير
كيف احنا نشوف وضع «هاف مليون» بالنسبة للمنافسين؟
لأن متأكد أنت مو قاعد تحصر نفسك بالمنافسين المحليين
أو العلامات التجارية المحلية
قاعد تشوف الناس اللي عندهم فروع كثير سواءً كانوا...
ممتاز، خليني أعطيك إياها بشكل عام في السوق
تتكلم في سوق المقاهي بس
لو استثنينا المقاهي الشعبية ومقاهي الشيشة
فتتكلم موجود في السعودية
ما في إحصائية دقيقة بشكل واضح
لكن تُقدَّر بـ25 ألف مقهى موجودة في السعودية
لو قسمناها، أيش العلامات التجارية اللي عندها من فرع إلى تسع فروع
خلينا نصنفها أنا وإياك أنها تكون علامات تجارية صغيرة
مو صغيرة أنها علامة تجارية صغيرة، قدر أنه مو بحجم فروعها
لأن ممكن علامات تجارية احنا مصنفينها صغيرة
لكن جودة المنتجات والخدمات أفضل من علامة تجارية عندها 200 فرع
والجزء الثاني خلينا نقسمهم إلى علامات تجارية متوسطة إلى كبيرة
اللي هو من عشر فروع وأكثر
تخيل 85% من الفروع الموجودة من 25 ألف
هذه تعتَبَر علامات تجارية صغيرة، عندها من فرع إلى تسعة فروع
و15% بس اللي هو علامات تجارية متوسطة وكبيرة
فسؤالي في البداية كان، هل كلهم تشوفوهم منافسين؟
إيه، عدد العلامات التجارية
أو عدد فروع العلامات التجارية اللي تملك عشرة فروع وأكثر
تتكلم ما يقارب 3500 فرع يملكها أربعين علامة تجارية
فهذه كلهم يعتبر منافس لـ«هاف مليون»
أو يتقاطع مع «هاف مليون» بشكل أو بآخر
موضوع المنافسة مهم لأنه يحفز
بس إذا أنت تقول: كل أحد يبيع قهوة منافسي
خلاص منافس كل السوق
أبي أعطيك مثال، في بعضهم يقول لك: يا أخي كنت أشرب قهوتي
من...، انسى «هاف مليون» علامة تجارية معينة
لكن بعدما شريت عندي الماكينة، صرت ما أروح له
فاهم وجهة نظرك، بس أنا أقيس على ردود الفعل
اللي أسمعها في محيطي سواءً كمتابعين أو أهل أو أصدقاء
يشربون قهوة من مكان معين، ويجونكم للمشروبات الباردة
وهذا أكثر انطباع أسمعه دائمًا عن «هاف مليون»
أنه أنا أروح للمشروبات الباردة ما أروح للمشروب الحار
فأنت فعليًّا، حتى لو أنا أروح لمقهى آخر، وأشرب منه مشروبي اليومي
أنا أجيك لأخذ المشروبات الباردة أو المثلجات
فممكن تكون هنا تنافس أحد ثاني، وهذا تنافس أحد
والله خليني أقول لك إياها: ذائقة عميل
في النهاية في عملاء يعجبه المنتج الفلاني عندنا
يقول: المنتج الفلاني هنا ما يعجبني
في النهاية هي أذواق
أنت ما تشوف أن المشروبات الباردة تمشي أكثر عندكم؟
يعتمد على حسب الموسم، أكيد في الصيف
أكيد في الصيف طبيعي
الباردة تمشي
بس إجمالًا يعني؟
لا، يمكن خيارات المشروبات الباردة أكثر
فعشان كذا بشكل عام يوضح أن مبيعات المنتجات الباردة أكثر من الحارة
لكن كخيارات ما هو قدر ما هو أن شايف جودته
بالعكس في عملاء للمنتج الفلاني، وفي عملاء لمنتج ثاني
فهو يعتمد صراحة على ذائقة العميل
هو عمومًا قرأت تقرير قبل كم يوم أن العملاء السعوديين
إجمالًا قاعدين يتوجهون الآن للمشروبات الباردة أكثر من...
ويحسبونه قهوة
أنا ما أعتب عليكم، أنا أعتب على مقهى ثاني
اللي يبيع لك مشروب فيه 70 ألف شيء مخلوط جوا
ويقول: هذه قهوة، أنت قاعد تشرب حلا
وخليني أقول لك: احنا عشان أذكرها في موضوع
أن وين احنا بالمنافسين
فعندنا احنا كل شهرين نسوي شيء اسمه «صحة العلامة التجارية»
اللي هو دراسة صحة العلامة التجارية
فنأخذ عينة عشوائية في السعودية
سعوديين وعرب وآسيويين في مناطق مختلفة
ونسألهم بعض الأسئلة بحيث نقيس مدى الوعي بالعلامة التجارية
فاحنا وين واصلين بالوعي؟
والعلامات التجارية الباقية وين واصلة في موضوع الوعي؟
فلاحظنا تطور كبير
أول ما بدأنا الدراسة في يناير 2022
كنا تتكلم على 40% من اللي سألناهم، كانوا يعرفون عن «هاف مليون»
الآن تتكلم على 60% من شهرين تقريبًا
هل قدرتوا تحددون أنتم وين مكانكم بين العلامات التجارية؟
خليني أقول لك: نعتبر من أعلى خمسة
مو بسهلين أعلى خمسة
من ناحية الوعي بالعلامة التجارية الآن
ومن ناحية تفضيل العملاء بالنسبة لنا
حلو، في برضو ما أدري إذا هذه جزء من الاستطلاعات
بس ذكرت في المؤتمر أو في الحفل
نسبة الرضا 94% أو 95%
إي
شلون توصلتوا لها؟
في واحدة من المعايير نقيسها اللي هو قياس رضا العملاء
بعد التجربة المباشرة، وظفنا فريق منفصل ومعزول
ومختص في موضوع قياس رضا العملاء
فخلال الفترة الماضية كان متوسط رضا العملاء تتكلم على 94%
شلون يقيسون رضا العملاء؟
يقيس لك على أكثر من شغلة
يقيس لك أول شيء على تصميم الفرع
يقيس لك على التعامل، ويقيس لك على المنتج
يقيس لك على المواقف، ويقيس لك على سرعة...
هو استفتاء وللا شلون؟